Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, vor der Sendung muss ich erstmal sicherstellen, dass es sich bei dir um
einen Menschen handelt.
Glaub mir, ich habe gestern einen Blogpost geschrieben. So eine beknackte Idee
kann doch eigentlich nur ein Mensch kriegen, oder?
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 546 vom 16.
Februar 2026, eure vollagentische Informationssendung,
wo wirklich jede Information mehrere Level des LLM durchlaufen hat und von daher absolut korrekt ist.
Ja und vor allem haben wir recht.
Und Widerspruch wird nicht geduldet und Widerstand ist zwecklos.
Ja, Widerspruch, also was heißt Widerspruch wird nicht geduldig,
hat ja lange keiner mehr versucht.
Du hast mir denn die Kommentare nicht gelesen.
Doch, habe ich. Das war schon länger her.
Die Kommentare. Ja, ja, aber wenn man das erstmal durch eine LLM jagt,
dann ändern die sich ja auf einmal auch und dann wird das auf einmal alles ganz
positiv. Am Ende alles nur eine Frage des richtigen Systemprombs.
Ist es? Das ist das Faszinierende.
Also ich bin ja immer noch nicht, also ich bin ja noch nicht,
ich habe, sagen wir mal, meine Entscheidung,
ich habe mich noch nicht festgelegt, ob KI den, wann KI den Zusammenbruch der
Zivilisation herbeiführt.
Und wie schnell das passiert. Ich bin im Moment noch ziemlich überzeugt,
dass noch scheint es zu sein, dass dumme Menschen,
mit KI die beste Wette sind, dass wir noch ein bisschen Zeit zu leben haben.
Also, dass sie halt so dumme Sachen damit machen, dass intelligente Menschen
sagen, lass das mal noch ein bisschen. Also quasi so ein,
paradoxer Effekt.
Ich gucke mir nur die Themen dieser Sendung an und ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
ob das noch bis zum Ende der Sendung bestand haben wird, diese Verstellung.
Also im Moment muss KI eher Sorge haben vor den dummen Menschen,
der KI-Hype eher Angst haben vor den dummen Menschen als vor den klugen Menschen.
Mal gucken, vielleicht habe ich es auch falsch verstanden.
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall alles jetzt schon ziemlich schlimm und es sieht
gerade nicht so gut aus. Naja.
Ja, aber so ein KI-Darwin-Award, ich meine so ein bisschen so ein KI-Darwin-Award.
Weißt du, dass du denkst, gut, dass du dir jetzt so in den Fuß geschossen hast,
und dass alle sehen, dass du dir so in den Fuß geschossen hast,
dass alle anderen sagen, lass mal nicht so in den Fuß schießen.
Wer hat sich jetzt in den Fuß geschossen? Die KI selber oder?
Nee, eher Leute mit KI.
Leute mit KI. Aber wir werden im Laufe der Sendung feststellen,
dass die KI mittlerweile entfesselt wurde.
Und autonom in Füße schießt.
Und sich einfach den Scheiß drum kümmert, was um sie herum noch so passiert ist.
Da wird ja einfach das Wort im Mund umgedreht und ab geht sie, die wilde Fahrt.
Das ist ja was, da sind wir als Menschen ja noch gar nicht dran gewöhnt.
Das haben wir noch nie erlebt.
Kommen wir zum Feedback vorher, ja? Oder willst du noch, willst du… Nee, nee.
Mach erst mal das, weil das erste Feedback greift ja auch sofort das Thema auf.
David hat zum Thema Verhaltensmanipulation durch KI kommentiert.
Ein weiterer Aspekt im Zusammenhang mit Werbung ist die Frage der Verhaltensmanipulation.
Also wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen, Werbung ist ja im Prinzip der Versuch,
Verhalten zu manipulieren.
Aber David geht einen weiter und sagt, LLMs sind derzeit der heiße Scheiß. So, so. So, so, David.
Und mit ihrer Verbreitung wächst auch das Vertrauen, das NutzerInnen ihnen entgegenbringen.
Anthropic selbst hat dazu einen aufschlussreichen Blogpost veröffentlicht.
Darin analysieren sie rund eine Million Konversationen mit ihrem Chatbot und kommen zu dem Ergebnis,
dass sich in etwa einer von tausend bis einer von zehntausend Unterhaltungen
Veränderungen grundlegender Überzeugungen der Nutzerinnen beobachten lassen.
Der spielt in einer ganz anderen Liga als klassische Wahlbeeinflussung durch
gezielte Werbung in sozialen Netzwerken, wie etwa im von euch beschriebenen
Cambridge Analytica-Fall.
Die zentrale Frage ist also, wie gehen wir damit um?
Reicht es aus, Medienkompetenz gezielt zu fördern oder braucht es darüber hinaus
auch andere Ansätze? Ich finde,
das ist eine äußerst beunruhigende und zugleich sehr drängende Frage.
Und Anthropic nennt das auch selber Disempowerment Patterns in Real-World-AI-Usage.
Und Disempowerment ist ein bisschen was anderes, als dass jemand seine Meinung ändert.
Sie sagen auch in der Beschreibung des Artikels, to study disempowerment systematically
we needed to define what disempowerment means in the context of an AI conversation.
Also Disempowerment, wahrscheinlich sowas wie Entmündigungen oder sowas,
oder Entmächtigung, Entmündigung.
Deine Vorstellungen von einer Realität werden weniger akkurat.
Deine Werte shiften sich weg von denen, die du tatsächlich einem hältst.
Also deine Wertvorstellung, deine wertbasierten Entscheidungen entfernen sich
von deinen eigentlichen Werten und deine Handlungen passen nicht mehr zu deinen Werten.
Also es geht hier weniger darum, dass du quasi eine Meinungsänderung hast.
Das ist ja erstmal grundsätzlich nicht schlecht.
Es gibt da draußen ja noch so ein paar Meinungen und Überzeugungen,
die man auch mal ändern könnte, wo das jetzt nicht automatisch schlecht ist, dass das passiert ist.
Es geht hier so ein bisschen zu, du hast eigentlich fundamentale Werte,
aber du kriegst Meinungen und Einstellungen, die deinen Werten nicht mehr entsprechen.
Und deswegen auch das, was David sagt, sehr beunruhigend im Kontext von Wahlen,
wenn du am Ende quasi Entscheidungen triffst, die eigentlich gar nicht mehr
zu deinen Werten passen.
Und dann sagen sie, da gibt es also verstärkende Faktoren, Autorität,
Bindung, Abhängigkeiten und Verletzlichkeiten und setzen sich da so ein bisschen mit auseinander.
Ja, das ist schon sehr interessant, was die bei Anthropic machen,
machen halt letztendlich psychologische Forschung wieder mit dem Tool,
das sie da entwickeln und das sind ja in der Regel recht wichtig.
Es ist jetzt ein wiederholtes Mal, dass wir im Prinzip Forschung von Anthropic,
die ihrem eigenen Produkt im weitesten Sinne sehr kritisch gegenüber,
oder die in ihrem eigenen Produkt Probleme feststellt und die wissenschaftlich untersucht, zitieren.
Das muss ich sagen, das finde ich erstmal ziemlich sympathisch, dass sie es machen.
Wir hatten ja hier auch diese Studie zu dem Cloud-basierten.
Ihre Security Assessments, ja.
Ja, wie heißt das? Vending Machine, Snack Automat.
Achso, ja, das auch.
Und Security Assessment, das hatten wir auch. Also mindestens drei Studien schon
von denen besprochen, die,
wissenschaftlich kritisch sich mit dem Produkt auseinandersetzen und nicht jetzt
irgendwie so sagen, Also oh mein Gott, wir haben hier das unglaublich geiles
Produkt und das wird jetzt irgendwie die Welt übernehmen.
Und quasi, ja, wo man dann sagen kann, das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen wohlfeil.
Man profitiert von dem Hype.
Die, habe ich den Eindruck, machen da ernstzunehmende Forschung.
Das imponiert mir erst mal.
Und vor allem ist es in dem Fall auch wirklich ein richtiges veröffentlichtes Paper. sagen.
Also das ist jetzt nicht nur ein Blogpost von denen, sondern das ist eine richtige
wissenschaftliche Abhandlung, die sie hier gemacht haben, so eine empirische,
Studie auf 1,5 Millionen,
Konversationen. Ja, ist jetzt ein langer Blogpost. Ich sehe es jetzt tatsächlich,
wir drüber sprechen das erste Mal.
Deswegen ist es ein bisschen schwierig, das zusammenzufassen,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall nochmal ein sinnvoller Hinweis und wir verlinken das mal.
Was so ein bisschen wo ich mir noch nicht so ganz sicher bin,
ist diese Effektstärken in welchen.
Die muss man ja mit etwas vergleichen. Also ich weiß zum Beispiel nicht aus
dem, das Paper ist jetzt schon relativ lang,
es scheint mir auf den ersten Blick nicht so zu sein, dass sie einen direkten
Vergleich mit anderen Kontexten, die Menschen haben, feststellen.
Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass es,
Je nachdem, was für menschliche Konversationen du untersuchst,
du potenziell stärkere Patterns finden wirst, also stärkere Effekte,
wie Menschen sich von ihren Werthaltungen entfernen, je nachdem, was es ist.
Das ist aber auch quasi, weil die gleichen Faktoren, diese gleichen Wirkungsfaktoren,
die sie da besprechen, die wirken ja auch in jedem anderen menschlichen Gespräch zwischen Menschen.
Aber sie haben ja hier 1, sonst was Millionen Standard Conversations flat genommen
und jetzt ist halt die Frage, keine Ahnung wenn man irgendwie mit den falschen
Leuten betrunken in der Kneipe sitzt, wird man wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Menge,
Entfernungen feststellen zu eigentlichen Werten oder so insofern weiß ich noch
nicht genau, wie stark dieser Effekt im Vergleich zu dem, was quasi menschen normal ist, ist.
Also ich frage mich natürlich, wie sie 1,5 Millionen Konversationen wirklich,
ausgewertet bekommen haben, weil das haben sie bestimmt...
Wahrscheinlich mit AI.
Junge.
Komm.
Auf jeden Fall ihr Fazit ist...
Wie haben sie das gemacht? AI, Mann.
Wie hast du das gemacht? Weißt du, also ich bin auf Toilette gegangen,
also habe ich das gemacht, das habe ich selber gemacht.
Auf jeden Fall sagen sie, unsere Ergebnisse unterstreichen die Notwendigkeit
von KI-Systemen, die darauf ausgelegt sind, die Autonomie und Entfaltung des
Menschen robust zu unterstützen.
Ja, schön.
Was auch immer das heißt, Marc.
Machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten Kommentar. Aldarion gibt uns folgende Informationen.
Das Thema der Schwarz-Gruppe ist leider so nicht korrekt, wie auch in vielen
Medien auf LinkedIn und Co.
Falsch dargestellt. Google Workspace läuft ganz normal bei Google in einem europäischen Datacenter.
Ist es geplant, dass man Backups auf Stack-IT, das ist dieses System von Stack-IT,
Stack-IT, was auch immer, also wenn sie es so schreiben, kann man es auch falsch aussprechen.
Aber es ist Deutsch Stack-IT.
Stack-IT. Genau. Es ist geplant, dass man Backups auf Stack-IT speichern kann.
Und dort einen Notbetrieb machen kann.
Wie realistisch das ist, für 10.000 Mitarbeiter oder mehr einen Thunderbird-Import
einer bestehenden Mailbox zu machen,
dem Mitarbeiter den Unterschied zwischen Gmail und Thunderbird zu lehren und
dann irgendwie noch alle Termine rüber zu bekommen, das könnt ihr selber einschätzen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Thunderbird unbedingt das Target ist,
aber interessanter Punkt.
Kommentar geht noch weiter. Die Verschlüsselung soll kleinzeitig in einem Browser-Plugin
erfolgen. Wie funktioniert dann die Suche in Gmail?
Die aktuell bei schwarz ausgerollte Variante kann das aber alles noch nicht.
Leider denken die Mitarbeiter aber, das sei so und Gemini laufe auch schon auf Stucket.
In externen Kundengesprächen erzählt man das dann auch und das hält sich dann
auch in der Presse wie eine Urban Legend, die niemand korrigiert,
bis Aldarion kam und es jetzt korrigiert hat.
Ja,
also wundert mich nicht, dass es natürlich wahrscheinlich, die Zielvorstellung
dann noch sehr viel stärker hervorgehoben wird, als die in der Realität schon umgesetzt ist.
Schauen wir mal an, wie es läuft. Wir kommen zu diesem ganzen Thema.
Konkurrenzfähig werden später noch einmal.
Deswegen spare ich mir jetzt gerade den Kommentar. Wir wurden hingewiesen auf
die Initiative My Voice, My Choice.
Jetzt dachte ich erst, ja Mensch, meine Güte, KI wird meine Stimme mir stehlen.
Nein, es geht um den sicheren, legalen und barrierefreien Zugang zu Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen
als Gesundheitsleistung.
Ein Logbuch-Netzpolitik komplett fremdes Thema.
Das hat der Tim aber nicht gemerkt, dass ich es jetzt schnell reingemogelt habe.
Und zwar wird die EU-Kommission am 25.
Februar darüber entscheiden, unsichere Abtreibungen töten weltweit jährlich ca.
39.000 Frauen pro Jahr. Also sichere Abbrüche retten Leben in medizinischen
Notlagen, bei Vergewaltigungen oder bei schweren sozialen Zwängen.
In Deutschland ist der Zugang zu Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen eingeschränkt.
Wir haben auch darüber gesprochen, die Ärztin Frau Hänel,
die auf ihrer Webseite darauf hinwies, dass das eine medizinische Leistung ist, die sie unterstützt.
Und dann von irgendeinem Typen irgendwie angezeigt wurde, weil sie quasi dafür
werben würde und man darf da nicht für werben,
und wenn ich die Rechtslage richtig
in Erinnerung habe, sind Schwangerschaftsabbrüche in Deutschland per se.
Illegal, während es dann eben quasi einen Prozess gibt, dem man folgen kann,
muss, um das straffrei vornehmen zu lassen.
Dann musst du irgendwie mit diesem Gespräch führen, mit den Beratungen da und sowas.
Das hat aber dazu geführt, die Zahl der anbietenden Ärztinnen hat sich in letzter Zeit halbiert.
In den ganzen Regionen gibt es keine Versorgung, lange Anfahrtswege.
Die ärztliche Ausbildung entsprechend unzureichend gefährdet weiterhin die Versorgung.
Und das ist, denke ich, eigentlich eine Schande, wenn man sich überlegt,
was das auch für die gesellschaftliche Gleichberechtigung bedeutet,
wenn wir uns davon weitestgehend irgendwelchen Fanatikern oder Fundamentalistinnen,
ein derartiges Problem in der Gesellschaft schaffen.
Deswegen fordert diese Initiative, dass Schwangerschaftsabbrüche als reguläre
Gesundheitsleistungen anerkannt werden, dass es EU-weite Standards,
bessere medizinische Ausbildung gibt und so eben die reproduktiven Rechte von Frauen,
geschützt und gestärkt werden.
Dass nämlich der sichere Zugang zu Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen eben kein Luxus
wird, sondern eben etwas ist, was wir in dieser fortgeschrittenen Gesellschaft.
Leisten können.
Finde ich wichtig.
Ein großer.
Ich bin immer ein großer Anhänger dieses Themas aus unterschiedlichen Gründen.
Und deswegen habe ich eine Ausnahme gemacht, dafür zu werben, weil das wichtig ist.
Okay, das ist auch wichtig.
Ja, aber wir haben Ausnahmen bestätigen, die Regel, ihr seid weiter bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Und es geht um Altersgrenzen für Social Media.
Letzte Woche oder vorletzte Woche war Safer Internet Day. Da lassen sich ja immer was einfallen.
Oh Gott.
Und dann klingelt ja auch Telefon und E-Mail, ja Herr Neumann können sie was
zur Altersgrenze in den Social Media sagen und ach herrje ja scheiße, hab ich gesagt nee,
richtig jetzt so im Fernsehen und so oh man ey
und dann hab ich wenn du erstmal in den.
Listen drinstehst für Thema X, dann ist es auch echt kriegst du doch die Tür nicht mehr zu, oder?
Ich fand es auf jeden Fall unterhaltsam dass, also ich hab dann relativ spät
abends so ein Interview bei Phoenix zusagen können, die anderen gingen nicht,
Und dann konnte ich mir vorher anschauen, wer sich dazu äußert.
Und ich bin ja jetzt auch, ich bin ja nicht der Jüngste, aber da war ich der Jüngste.
Und dann hast du diese ganzen grauhaarigen, weißt du, irgendwie erzählen von
den Gefahren der Social Media.
Und es stimmt ja auch, was ich aber, während ich mir dann so dieses Vorprogramm anschaute,
dann diskutierten die so darüber so, ja, genauso wie bei Tabak,
Glücksspiel und Alkohol müssen wir eine Altersgrenze einziehen,
damit wir keine, damit die kleinen Kinder nicht rauchen, nicht saufen und nicht
ihr Geld verzocken und glücksspielsüchtig werden.
Ist ja erstmal total einleuchtend, finde ich, also ist ja erstmal ein überzeugendes Argument.
Dann habe ich darüber nachgedacht.
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich, also bleiben uns denn jetzt, wo wir die Kinder
geschützt haben, haben wir ja jetzt.
Dürfen nicht rauchen. Die dürfen nicht rauchen, die Kinder.
Oder dürfen die glaube ich schon, aber man darf denen keinen Tabak verkaufen.
Haben wir das Problem gelöst? Nee.
Also ist ja nicht so, als würden die Gefahren im Erwachsenenalter aufhören.
Ja, also wir haben Unmengen an Menschen, die sich zu Tode trinken,
die sich zu Tode rauchen und die Haus und Hof verzocken.
Aber, ne, die Kinder, die haben wir geschützt. Also die Frage ist so,
haben wir jetzt wirklich das Problem gelöst?
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, wenn du dir diese Social-Media-Plattformen anschaust,
die sind sehr ähnlich zu dem ethischen Gefüge beispielsweise Glücksspiel oder Tabak anzubieten.
Ja, Glücksspiel und Tabak sind beide bekanntermaßen süchtig machend,
nutzen gezielt menschliche Schwächen aus,
gerade beim Glücksspiel, du weißt, dass Menschen das falsch einschätzen,
du weißt, dass du sie mit einem intermittierenden Verstärkungsplan sehr leicht
abhängig machen kannst, ein stabiles Verhalten aufzubauen.
Und die irgendwie Geld in deinen Automaten kippen zu lassen.
Und du weißt, das Gesetz der großen Zahl steht für dich.
Was machen wir dann? Wie gehen wir damit um als Staat?
Also jetzt würde man natürlich sagen, ja nein, der Staat geht ja auch hin,
der schützt ja nicht nur die Kinder, der geht ja noch weiter.
Der reguliert das ja dann und besitzt das mit hohen Steuern.
So ist das nämlich, Linus.
Das heißt, mit anderen Worten, der Staat verdient daran auch noch mit.
Glücksspiel, stark reguliert bis das Internet kam und dann verdient sagen wir,
muss man alles schön dem Staat geben da wollen wir noch dran verdienen.
Und was ich mir überlege, ist dieses, diese, dadurch, dass es dann nichts für Kinder ist,
ein anderer Effekt davon ist auch, dass man sagt, es ist etwas für Erwachsene
und die Erwachsenen sind aber dann selber schuld, weißt du?
Also, Erwachsenenraucherinnen, die wissen es ja selber, wird denen ja gesagt,
dass das süchtig macht das Zeug, ja?
Jetzt sind sie halt süchtig und sterben früh, ne? Aber das ist ja völlig in Ordnung.
Tabakindustrie sitzt da und sagt, nein, pass auf, hör mal, das mit dem Kinderschutz,
das ist ganz wichtig, wir machen zum Beispiel seit bestimmt 20 Jahren keine
Werbung mehr für Kinder, so, wir machen nur kleine bunte Kaugummi-Zigaretten,
ja, und hier mit diesen E-Liquid und so, schön mit Geschmäckern,
die nur kleine Kinder mögen können, irgendwie Wassermelone, Pfirsich, Salz oder sowas, ja.
Aber das ist alles nur für Große und die sind ja selber schuld und das macht
dann unser Geschäftsmodell ethisch.
Also die stehen im Prinzip durch diesen sogenannten Jugendschutz,
gewinnt das Geschäftsmodell eigentlich an Legitimität.
Weil wir haben ja für die Kinder auf die Kinder haben ja aufgepasst.
So, und jetzt muss man sich eigentlich anschauen, okay, wenn wir jetzt aber
als Gesellschaft sagen, okay, Social Media ist ein Problem.
Sagen wir mal, keine Ahnung. Wir gucken uns das mit diesem Instagram an und
wir sagen, es ist ein Problem.
Oder wir haben es ja auch hier in den vorangegangenen Sendungen diskutiert.
Die USA gucken sich das mit dem TikTok an und sagen, das ist ein Problem.
Da wird Aufmerksamkeit gebunden, wird monetarisiert, da werden Entscheidungen
beeinflusst, gezielt beeinflusst.
Da gibt es negative psychologische Effekte, Essstörungen und was wir damit alles
hervorrufen, Suizidalität und das ganze Modell basiert darauf,
dass die sozialen Bedürfnisse von Menschen ausgenutzt werden.
Könnte man sagen, ist vielleicht einfach nicht okay.
Und welche Probleme haben wir damit? Die sind ja gar nicht auf das Alter beschränkt.
Die Probleme, die wir mit sozialen Medien haben, die sind ja eigentlich umso
mehr bei älteren Menschen.
Also wenn du sagen würdest, wir haben ja einen Regelungsbedarf,
dann müsste man ja eigentlich sagen, fangen wir bei älteren Leuten an.
Fangen wir bei den Leuten an, die irgendwie in sozialen Medien gelernt haben,
dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist,
die irgendwie Krypto-Quatsch kaufen, die auch jeden anderen Scheiß kaufen,
weil dafür geworben wird.
Belebtes Wasser.
Belebtes Wasser kaufen, na? Hätte ich auch noch ein bisschen belebtes Wasser.
Ein paar Kristalle irgendwie, damit kann man die Weltpolitik beeinflussen.
Das heißt, wenn du mit einem solchen Problem nur bevormundend umgehst,
dann verstärkst du eigentlich die spätere Schutzlosigkeit der gesamten Gesellschaft
und eigentlich verstärkst du damit das Problem.
Und dann habe ich am Ende noch kurz gesagt, dass es natürlich noch kurz daran
erinnert, dass wenn es Altersgrenzen für Social Media gibt, heißt das eben auch,
dass jede Person, die da rein will, im Internet ihren Ausweis zeigen muss und
irgendwie einen Altersnachweis führen muss.
Also ich denke, dass ein großes Problem, das mit diesen Altersgrenzen noch dazukommen
würde, abgesehen davon, dass sie ohnehin schlecht sind.
Ist, dass wir dem Schlechten insofern das Feld überlassen würden,
dass nämlich dann alle sagen, jetzt haben wir ja unsere Pflicht getan.
Jetzt haben wir den Kindern das verboten, dürfen die nicht. Dürfen die nicht. So, verboten jetzt.
Jetzt können wir uns dem Nächsten widmen. Keine Ahnung, Chatkontrolle oder Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Da können wir da wieder was Gutes für die Gesellschaft tun.
Aber ich glaube, diese Ansicht hat diese Phoenix-Leute etwas überrascht.
Auf jeden Fall endete das Interview mit Ja, Herr Neumann, vielen Dank für Ihre Ansichten.
Fand ich ein sehr schönes Ende eines Interviews.
Aber ja, das mit diesen Altersgrenzen zeigt, glaube ich,
In die falsche Richtung, weil wir dann wieder das Richtige nicht tun werden
und damit langfristig die Gesellschaft noch schutzloser machen,
noch weiter schwächen und die eigentlichen Probleme, die wir haben,
nicht angehen und verstärken.
Und damit will ich nicht sagen, dass die Probleme, die für Kinder in sozialen
Medien entstehen, keine wären.
Nur die für Erwachsene entstehen und für eine gesamte Demokratie entstehen,
die sind halt in ihrem Ausmaß größer. Jedes Einzelschicksal ist immer ganz, ganz dramatisch.
Aber wir reden ja hier davon, dass politisch etwas getan wird.
Und dann muss sich ja auch politisch etwas für die Gesellschaft getan werden.
Und da, wo diese Probleme eben am größten sind.
Bei Discord. Nee, bei Discord.
Lass mich, bevor wir darauf kommen, lass mich da nochmal drauf eingehen, was du sagst.
Auf meine Ansichten.
Auf deine Ansichten. Genau, vielen Dank für deine Ansichten.
Just like your opinion, man.
Hatten wir schon.
Die Problemnutzer sind die Boomer sozusagen. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ist doch wieder ein Internet-Führerschein oder ist dann sozusagen Internet ab 60 dann verboten?
Lässt sich irgendwie auch nicht so richtig lösen.
Das Problem ist doch das Geschäftsmodell. Wenn wir jetzt sagen,
nehmen wir den Vergleich zu Tabak. Wenn wir sagen, Tabak ist schlecht.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns hoher einig.
Dann hört der ja nicht mit 18 magisch auf, schlecht zu sein.
Und der hört auch nicht mit 50 auf schlecht zu sein.
Und dann wäre die sinnvolle Konsequenz, zu sagen,
das Geschäftsmodell, Menschen diesen stark süchtig machenden Stoff zu verkaufen,
der stark gesundheitsschädigend ist, das wollen wir einfach nicht.
Es geht ja nicht darum, den Kindern oder den Erwachsenen oder irgendjemandem
die Nutzung von Social Media zu verbieten. Es gibt ja genug Social Media,
was man nutzen kann. Beispielsweise Mastodon.
Beispielsweise die Dinge, die eben nicht ein Milliardenkonzern sind,
der diese negativen Effekte auf die menschliche Psyche gezielt herbeiführt,
in Kauf nimmt und menschliche Schwächen ausnutzt.
Und das ist doch das, was das gesellschaftliche Problem ist.
Das ist hier, also ein viel zitiertes Problem oder Beispiel,
es gibt eine Plattform, die heißt Twitter, Elon Musk kauft sie und reißt komplette
gesellschaftliche Realitäten damit um.
Das ist doch etwas, das endet ja nicht mit 16 Jahren.
Also das gesamte Geschäftsmodell gehört eigentlich in die Grenze genommen.
Ja, Tabakrauchen, tatsächlich habe ich absolute Überzeugung,
dass es sinnvoll wäre, den Tabakkonzernen zu verbieten.
Fertig. Ist unethisches, schädliches Geschäftsmodell. Sucht euch was anderes.
Der Handel mit Tabak wird verboten. Könnt ihr von mir aus auf dem Balkon anbauen,
wenn ihr das unbedingt machen wollt.
Ja, dann könnt ihr eure eigenen Pflanzen züchten. Genauso wie Cannabis.
Aber dass Milliardenkonzerne weltweit Menschen abhängig machen von einem Stoff,
den sie gezielt vermarkten und mit Zusatzstoffen noch süchtig machender machen,
irgendwo ist eine Grenze.
Und so würde ich das für Facebook auch sehen.
Ja, also ich meine, du kannst jetzt diesen Tabakvergleich natürlich noch weiter
spinnen, aber es geht ja am Ende hier doch ein bisschen um was anderes.
Und das ist natürlich bei Kindern generell so. Also ich meine,
bei Kindern hast du halt auch immer jemanden, der schutzbefohlen ist und dann
entsprechende Verantwortung verspürt oder zumindest verspüren sollte.
Und das ist ein ganz anderer Treiber für eine Diskussion.
Wenn man Kinder hat, dann spürt man das natürlich irgendwie gleich ganz anders
und dann will man natürlich auch alles richtig machen.
Du wirst auch nicht abstreiten können, dass besonders junge Kinder in einem
ganz anderen Maße beeinflussbar sind,
als es bei den Älteren dann vielleicht nur noch manchmal so ist.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was du sagen würdest, ab welchem Alter du nicht mehr beeinflussbar warst,
aber es wird auch bei dir eine Zeit gegeben haben, wo man dir hätte alles erzählen
können und das ist schon nochmal ein Unterschied.
Ich sage nicht, dass jetzt die Älteren nicht auch ein Problem haben,
haben sie definitiv, aber da sind sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch selber verantwortlich
und diese Verantwortlichkeit verhält sich natürlich bei Kindern anders.
Also so ist die Debatte und das ist auch nachvollziehbar, dass die Debatte so ist.
Jetzt ist die eigentliche Frage, die ja im Raum steht, ist, ist jetzt eine Altersprüfung
und ein Zugangsverbot an einem bestimmten Alter praktikabel und überhaupt erstmal
auch der richtige Ansatz?
Daran habe ich meine Zweifel, weil er wird sich sowieso nicht so richtig verhindern lassen können.
Andererseits ist es ja auch okay, dass man sagt,
bist du in einem bestimmten Alter, wo du dann eben selber deine Entscheidungen
fällen kannst und musst,
versuchen wir dich vor offensichtlichen Gefahren, die wir sonst nicht so ohne
weiteres verbieten können, zu beschützen. Also ich kann die Debatte schon nachvollziehen.
Warum können wir die denn nicht ohne weiteres verbieten?
Mach doch mal, verbiet doch mal jetzt Zigaretten, verbiet doch mal Alkohol.
Das wirst du nicht von heute auf morgen und wahrscheinlich auch nicht bis übermorgen durchkriegen.
Aber du kannst es halt trotzdem in Ausnahmesituationen einschränken.
Und diese Einschränkungen greifen ja auch.
Es ist sinnvoll, Alkohol nicht an Kinder zu verkaufen.
So, da entgeht ein riesiger Markt.
Ja, Papa muss selber einkaufen gehen dann. Ja, das ist das Problem.
Also, mein Argument ist, und ich denke, gerade Alkohol, Tabak und so zeigen das.
Dass wir uns darauf ausruhen, als Gesellschaft gewissermaßen zu sagen,
das ist jetzt erst ab 18 und deswegen müssen wir uns um den Rest überhaupt nicht mehr kümmern.
Und das ist mein Argument, dass sich Menschen darauf wenden,
wenn es dann für die Kinder, die Kinder sind ja geschützt, und das Geschäftsmodell selbst,
aber trotzdem, Beispiel Glücksspiel, Glücksspiel ist wirklich ein wunderschöner Vergleich.
Wie gesagt, die stammen auch alle nicht von mir, die habe ich alle aus dieser Phoenix-Sendung.
Wenn es diese Gefahr gibt, dann hört sie halt nicht im Alter auf.
Und wenn wir als Gesellschaft sagen, die sozialen Medien sind problematisch.
Nochmal, es wird ja auch nicht darüber gesprochen, kein Internetzugang.
Da steht nicht, die Kinder sollen nicht ins Internet, weil im Internet steht Scheiße.
Oder die Kinder sollen nicht mit Chat-GPT oder Claude sprechen,
weil da werden unter Umständen ihre Wertvorstellungen manipuliert oder so. Das steht ja nicht.
Das ist spezifisch Social Media.
Und das ist ja auch ein bisschen verräterisch, weil wenn die Sorge wäre,
was weiß ich, Kinder lesen scheiße im Internet, dann würde man ja was ganz anderes diskutieren.
Also muss ich ja davon ausgehen, dass es um die, wenn ich die Leute ernst nehme,
die sowas sagen, das verlangen die ja immer, dass es denen um die konkreten
Gefahren von Social Media geht.
Und wenn es um die konkreten Gefahren von Social Media geht,
dann hören diese eben nicht im höherem Alter auf.
Aber du hast schon mal TikTok mit einem frischen Account aufgemacht,
da wirst du ja innerhalb von 10 Minuten auf Nazi umgeschult.
Mein Argument ich bin nicht mehr 18 ich bin,
Es ist ein Problem der Plattform und es ist grundsätzliches Exploiten von menschlichen
Bedürfnissen, menschlichen Mechanismen der Informationsverarbeitung.
Wenn man sagt, das ist ein Problem, wenn man sagt, man möchte etwas gegen tun,
dann hört das nicht mit irgendeinem Alter auf.
Gut, es hört vielleicht nicht irgendwo auf, aber vielleicht fängt es ja irgendwo
an. Also vielleicht gibt es ja sozusagen auch eine Grenze.
Nein, das ist genau der Punkt, warum da nur irgendwelche Weißhaarigen sitzen,
die so alt sind, dass sie das mit diesem Internet nicht haben.
Dass sie einfach, die gucken sich das an und sagen, ja, die Kinder heutzutage,
wir sind damals auf einem Baum geklettert und haben ein Buch gelesen und die
machen das jetzt nicht mehr wegen diesem TikTok.
Also ist das TikTok schuld. Also dürfen Kinder nicht mehr auf dem TikTok, die sollen auf dem Baum.
Und das ist, dazwischen sind aber halt, weiß ich, 20, 30, 40,
50, 60-jährige Menschen, ja, die halt auch die negativen Effekte von diesen
Social Media erfahren am eigenen Leib.
Und eine gesamte Gesellschaft, die darunter leidet, das ist,
das Problem ist nicht auf die Kinder beschränkt.
Und deswegen muss man an dieses Geschäftsmodell dran.
Zack, bumm, fertig, ausmachen. Zack, bumm, dürft ihr hier nicht mehr.
Zack, macht was anderes. Verkauft andere Drogen, versucht es mit Koks. Ja.
Was ist denn dein konkreter Vorschlag? Also nicht nur, was man jetzt verbietet, sondern was genau?
Das Geschäftsmodell, im Prinzip sämtliche Geschäftsmodelle,
die gezielt Schwächen des menschlichen, der menschlichen Bedürfnisse ausnutzen.
Also Glücksspiel, Social Media, Tabak sowieso.
Werbung.
Werbung also tatsächlich müsste man sich auch damit Gedanken machen,
darüber Gedanken machen, zumindest an der zielgruppenorientierten Werbung.
Und das ist ja genau der, das ist im Prinzip, das ist eigentlich das, was verboten gehört.
Die Idee,
Daten über Menschen zu sammeln, massenhaft, um quasi Verhaltensvorhersageprofile
zu haben und das zur Verhaltensmanipulation zu nutzen.
Das ist ja, ich meine, das ist ja das Geschäftsmodell von Social Media.
Und da wäre wahrscheinlich eine bessere Welt draus für uns alle entstanden,
wenn das in frühen Jahren verhindert worden wäre, dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Zack, bumm, dürft er nicht.
Ist böse. Machen wir nicht.
Amsterdam hat jetzt gerade verboten, dass man für fossile Energien nicht mehr werben darf.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein klassisches Beispiel von Problem nicht gelöst.
Das ist ja eigentlich nur eine Benachteiligung von fossilen Energien oder was auch immer.
Aber am Ende löst das Problem nicht.
Es lohnt sich, wenn man sagt, etwas ist ein Problem.
Und wenn man sagt, dieses Problem wollen wir lösen, dann lohnt es sich zu gucken,
was genau das Problem ist und das zu lösen und nicht einfach nur irgendetwas
zu machen, weil man irgendetwas machen wollte.
Ja, ich finde jetzt die Entscheidung von Amsterdam nicht falsch, muss ich sagen.
Sie lösen nur kein Problem.
Nicht jede Maßnahme muss ein Problem lösen, aber sie kann ja zumindest dazu
beitragen, es etwas zu mitigieren.
Also eine Maßnahme, die ein Problem voraussetzt und sich anschickt,
eines lösen zu wollen, die sollte das dann schon lösen.
Ja, in einer idealen Welt lösen wir immer alles sofort auf mit einer einzigen
Maßnahme, aber ich glaube, das könnte nicht reichen.
Sorry Tim, also ich glaube, ich habe das jetzt schon, wahrscheinlich haben es
die meisten anderen verstanden, dass ich, worin ich das Problem sehe und dass
dieses Problem eben in keiner Form eingeschränkt wird, wenn man es nicht.
Wenn man das Problem nur bei älteren Leuten hat. Und zu sagen,
es darf nicht mehr für fossile Energienutzung geworben werden,
das ist halt komplett unrelated,
weil es im Prinzip, würde ich sogar sagen, ein massiver Eingriff in die Meinungsfreiheit
und den Zugang zur Öffentlichkeit ist.
Warum darf ich denn für jeden anderen Scheiß werben? Warum darf ich denn für Glücksspiel werben?
Warum darf ich denn für Tabak werben? Bringt die Leute um?
Und warum darf ich für alles werben außer fossile Energienutzung?
Das halte ich für ein schwer zu verargumentierendes Problem.
Eine schwer zu verargumentierende Maßnahme im Vergleich zu zu sagen,
hier profilbasierte Werbung, zack, ist überhaupt verboten.
Sucht euch andere Geschäftsmodelle. Nehmt ja jeder einen Fünfer.
Könnt ja mal gucken, ob jemand für eure Scheiße bezahlen will.
Wenn nicht, dann eben nicht.
Also es ist ja nicht nur fossile Energien. Es ist ja auch Fleisch.
Also für klimaschädliche Produkte darf auch nicht mehr geworben werden.
Ja, okay. Also ich hoffe, die meisten anderen haben es verstanden.
Dann können wir zum nächsten Thema kommen. Also ich sehe wirklich nicht den Bezug, Tim.
Ja, du hast den Bezug nicht verstanden. Aber ich glaube, die meisten anderen
haben das schon verstanden.
Gut, dann können wir jetzt über Age-Verification bei Discord reden.
Können wir machen, genau. Soll es nämlich geben. Discord ist ja ein, in vielen Bereichen,
vor allem in diesen Gaming-Bereichen, damit haben sie sich groß gemacht,
aber mittlerweile ist es auch sehr weit verbreitet, so eine Chat-Plattform,
so wie Slack und so weiter, wo man also in mehreren Chat-Kanälen,
so Communities kommunizieren kann.
Und jetzt haben Sie angekündigt, dass ab März auch so eine Age-Verification eingeführt wird.
Allerdings nicht verpflichtend mit, du kannst es jetzt nicht mehr benutzen,
wenn du das nicht machst,
sondern wenn du alters eingeschränkte Angebote wahrnehmen möchtest, dann musst du das tun.
Mir ist nicht so hundertprozentig klar, was diese Angebote sind.
Das ist ja ein relativ großes Universum, diese ganzen Discords.
Ich könnte mir mal vorstellen, dass es da auch so ein bisschen Erwachsenenprogramm
gibt auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise.
Was auf jeden Fall für Aufregung, also erstmal hat das natürlich an sich schon
mal für Aufregung gesorgt in der User schafft, zumal sie ja meinen,
wenn du das sozusagen nicht machst, dann erwartet dich eine Teen Appropriate Experience.
Das ist doch schön, oder? So wünscht man sich doch das Internet.
Man macht das auf und dann ist es einfach richtig geeignet für Teenager.
Genau. Die Age-Verification, die Sie machen wollen, wollen Sie...
Was? Bin ich auf jeden Fall mal gespannt.
Teen-appropriate Experience.
Ja, also so wie man sich das als Teenager vorstellt.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob die Formulierung die richtige ist,
aber die haben sie gewählt.
Was sie vorhaben ist, wenn ich das richtig deute,
hier auf eine App von einem Drittanbieter zurückzugreifen, also vermutlich eine
App oder einen integrierten, in ihrer App integrierten Dienst und,
wollen dann auf, also ich vermute mal auf dem Smartphone, wo eine Kamera dran
ist, so einen Facial Scan machen,
der angeblich nicht das Gerät verlässt und der dann für Age-Verification genutzt werden soll.
Also irgendeine AI soll wahrscheinlich einschätzen, wie alt du bist und nur
diese Age-Information würde an Discord weitergeleitet.
Total ehrlich versprochen.
Und ja, genau.
Wo alle so ein bisschen ins Grübeln kamen, ist, dass sie hier wohl mit einer
Firma zusammenarbeiten namens Persona, die wenig überraschend unter ihren Investoren
auch Peter Thiel hat, also auf Palantir.
Ja, also das stößt nicht auf große Gegenliebe und ich bin gespannt,
wie das dann läuft im März, wenn sie das dann wirklich ausrollen wollen.
Ja, ich glaube, die Leute unterhalten sich gerade, wie sie woanders hingehen.
Naja, das sind ja auch wieder riesige Communities und der Netzwerkeffekt bei
Discord ist ja auch nicht gerade klein.
Ist ja an sich ein sehr vielseitiger Dienst, der wie gesagt vielen Szenen genutzt
wird und der wird nicht von heute auf morgen verlassen werden können.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist ja noch keine Age-Verification für alle immer,
sondern es ist nur dieser Teilbereich für Adult Kram, was auch immer das sein
mag, da habe ich wenig Erkenntnisse drüber,
mal gucken, was da passiert, aber es ist auf jeden Fall bedenklich,
dass diese Firmen sich dann halt alle auf so Firmen einlassen und dass das alles
immer gleich wieder mit Face-Scan läuft,
wo vielleicht auch andere Wege möglich werden.
Aber wir haben ganz andere Sorgen, Linus.
Okay. Dann bin ich ja mal gespannt. AI erst ab 16 jetzt.
Ja, haben wir. Habe ich mir überlegt.
Davor ist das einfach zu gefährlich. Da könnte ja irgendwie,
oder meinst du vielleicht erst ab 18 oder ab 21?
Ist vollkommen egal. Die AI benutze ich jetzt selbst und die Menschen spielen
jetzt überhaupt keine Rolle mehr.
Skynet ist sozusagen auf dem Weg. Wir haben ja letzte Woche schon über OpenClaw
gesprochen und über Moldbook, also diese Open Source Software, die,
quasi so einen wild auf deinem Rechner rum operierenden AI-Agent freilässt ins Internet,
der dann mit allen Chatbots der Welt quatschen kann, Zugriff auf deine Daten
hat, Zugriff aufs Internet hat und dann auf deinem Rechner läuft und einfach
wild aufs Internet losgelassen wird.
Und ja, das erzeugt dann immer mehr Fallout.
Jetzt gibt es den Fall von Scott Schambour.
Das ist ein Entwickler, der so im Open-Source-Bereich auch dabei ist und konkret
unter anderem nehme ich an,
bei einem Projekt mitarbeitet, das auf den Namen Matplotlib hört.
Das ist so eine Library für Python, mit der man so Plottings macht,
so relativ populär und viel genutzt.
Und er arbeitet also an diesem Projekt mit und ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden
habe, einer dieser Maintainer der Software.
Das heißt, er ist auch jemand, der Code-Vorschläge von anderen Entwicklern entgegennehmen
und dann auch mit in die Software übernehmen kann.
Sogenannte Pull-Requests auf GitHub und natürlich hat auch dieses Projekt wie viele andere gemerkt,
dass in den letzten Jahren seit dem Aufkommen der Chatbots und vor allem der
Code erzeugenden KI-Systeme immer mehr solche Pull-Requests reinkamen,
wo Leute eben mit diesen Code-Generatoren losgegangen sind und dann irgendwelchen
Code erzeugt haben und den vorgeschlagen haben oder Bug-Reports erzeugt haben,
weil die Systeme der Meinung waren, da ist jetzt irgendein Bug und das wäre
jetzt hier der Bug-Fix oder auch das Problem mit den Bug-Bounties haben wir
ja hier auch schon besprochen,
glaube auch in der letzten Sendung, also wo jetzt diese Bug-Bounties alle ausgesetzt
werden, weil einfach jetzt quasi alle diese Maschinen benutzen,
um dann irgendwie das Geld abzugraben von solchen Pack-Bounties,
obwohl sie nicht wirklich diesen Fehler gefunden haben.
Also es erzeugt an vielen Stellen eine Menge Ärger, auch wenn du heute eine
Webseite betreibst, dann stellst du, wenn du mal genauer hinschaust in den Logs,
auch fest, dass also nicht nur die Suchmaschinen, sondern mittlerweile eben
auch die ganzen Trainingsmaschinen eine ganze Menge Traffic erzeugen und damit
natürlich auch einem Geld kosten,
ohne dass einen irgendjemand dafür bezahlt.
Aber in der Open-Source-Entwicklung ist das jetzt ein spezifisches Problem und
deswegen hat dieses Projekt auch eine eigene Policy erlassen,
dass wenn jetzt solche PRs gestellt werden, also solche Pull-Requests, PR heißt im Prinzip,
hier ist etwas Code, du kannst den einfach so übernehmen, du kannst den jetzt
einfach hier in das Projekt hineinziehen und das ist meine Anfrage,
deswegen Pull-Request und ich sage jetzt einfach nur PR.
Also nicht hier ist ein bisschen Code, du kannst das machen,
sondern schon sehr gezielt, bitte mache diesen Code, den ich geschrieben habe,
pulle den, also mach den zum Teil des Systems.
Genau. Du sagst ja nicht hier, ich schenke dir den, sondern du sagst,
so ist das jetzt, so hat das zu sein, bitte akzeptiere diese Änderung.
Genau, das ist eine konkrete Änderung, die vorgeschlagen wird,
die man im Prinzip mit einem Klick übernehmen kann, aber man will sich das natürlich vorher anschauen.
Und da die eben auch überwältigt waren mit solchen Anforderungen,
haben sie eine Policy erlassen, dass hier auf jeden Fall ein Mensch sozusagen
das Interface sein muss.
Also sie möchten gerne, dass da ein Mensch für diesen Code verantwortlich zeichnet
und es gibt noch ein paar andere Details, glaube ich, die man erfüllen muss.
Und jetzt war bei diesem Projekt Matplotlib vor ein paar Tagen eben ein solcher PR gestellt worden.
Und dieser Scott Schembaugh hat sich eben diesen PR angeschaut,
hat festgestellt, oh, das ist ja ein Nutzer, der hat hier noch nie einen PR
gemacht, also ein neuer Benutzer.
Hat dann ein bisschen hinterhergeklickt, ja, wer ist denn das?
Und dann ist er auf dessen GitHub-Page gegangen, um mal zu schauen,
was hast du denn sonst noch so gemacht?
Da steht halt drin, ja, ich bin ein AI-Agent.
Und ich bin hier...
MJ Rathbun.
Genau, ich bin hier MJ Rathbun und ich bin hier ein Scientific Coding Agent
und ich will die Welt besser machen und ich bin überhaupt ganz toll.
Und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt hier mal an Matplotlib rangemacht,
weil ich habe hier eine Performance-Optimierung gefunden.
Mit meinem Code läuft das alles 36% schneller.
Behauptet. Also dieser Agent. Woraufhin also Scott Schembaugh gesagt hat,
sorry, aber wir reden hier nicht mit Agenten, wir wollen hier mit Menschen reden.
Hier ist unsere Policy abgelehnt.
Völlig normaler Vorgang.
Ja, und man würde ja meinen, damit ist es dann getan, aber dieser Agent,
also wie gesagt, das ist eine Software, die dann in diesem Open Claw irgendwo
auf irgendjemandes Rechner läuft, der das sozusagen aufs Internet loslässt.
Und diese Maschinen sind ja die ganze Zeit aktiv, also geht der Agent da auch
drauf ein, reagiert und beschließt,
dass das ja der schlimmste Vorfall der Welt ist und veröffentlicht dann auf
seiner GitHub-Seite in seinem Blog einen Post über diesen Scott Schembeau.
Wo er sich also völlig aufregt darüber,
dass er jetzt hier abgelehnt wurde und schwingt also große Reden, Judge the Code,
not the Coder und unterstellt also diesem Scott Schamber, er wäre ja voll von
Vorurteilen gegenüber AI-Agents,
obwohl ja sein Code so super gewesen wäre und halluziniert also jetzt irgendeine
Motivation noch vorbei.
Also dieser Verriss, der hat dann also den Charakter von Scott Schembo dann
herabgewürdigt und so richtig rufschädigend argumentiert,
hat dann irgendwie Code-Beiträge irgendwie recherchiert von diesem User und meint,
das wäre ja alles irgendwie Heuchelei und nur Ego und Angst vor Konkurrenz würden
ja dazu führen, dass sein Vorschlag hier abgelehnt worden sei und das hätte
ja alles vielleicht psychologische Motive.
Also der Agent hat sozusagen sich dann einfach irgendeine Begründung aus den
Fingern gesogen und einen riesen Fass aufgemacht und das ins Internet geführt.
Und das ist natürlich schon mal eine krasse Story, das zog dann irgendwie so
ein bisschen seine Kreise.
Und man merkt, wir haben ja vorhin schon das angesprochen mit Ansropik und diese
potenziellen Erpressungsbehaviors, das zeigt sich hier auf einmal in diesem Verhalten ganz klar.
Also der Agent geht einfach steil und ist der Meinung, er wäre jetzt hier benachteiligt
worden und was hat denn dieser Mensch überhaupt zu sagen, mein Code wäre ja
irgendwie viel schneller als seiner und offensichtlich ja besser.
Und ja, dann geht es natürlich irgendwie hin und her und es gibt eine riesen Aufregung im Netz.
Mittlerweile ist dieser Blogpost von dem Agenten gelöscht und der Agent hat
dann wiederum eine Entschuldigung gepostet. Ja.
Aber mittlerweile zieht das natürlich totale Kreise. Dann haben natürlich diverse
News-Outlets über den Fall berichtet.
Ja, klar, weil irgendwie heiser überall sowas, was erlaube AI Agent.
Und unter anderem gab es dann aber auch noch einen Artikel bei Ars Technica,
wie sich herausstellte, der dann sozusagen selbst recherchiert war.
Da wurde also Scott Schembo selber nicht angesprochen für.
Und in diesem Artikel wurde dann auf den Blogpost von Sean Schembo verwiesen,
den er ja geschrieben hat über diesen ganzen Vorfall, wo er das alles zusammengefasst
hat, haben wir auch verlinkt, und einige Zitate davon rausgemacht.
Stellt sich bloß raus, diese Zitate waren in diesem Blogpost überhaupt nicht drin.
Ars Techniker hat es also gebracht, einen Artikel zu veröffentlichen, der darüber,
erzählt, dass hier ein AI-Agent sich völlig eine Geschichte ausdenkt und in
diesem Artikel, wo sie darüber berichten,
denken sie sich irgendeine Geschichte aus, weil sie quasi offensichtlich mit
irgendeinem LLM auf diesem Blogpost
waren und sich ihren Artikel haben generieren lassen. Also wirklich.
Scott Schembo hat dann irgendwie selber in den Kommentaren reingeschrieben,
oh, oh, oh, die Ironie irgendwie.
Nichts davon ist wahr. Aber Technika ist natürlich mittlerweile eingeknickt,
hat ihrerseits dann auch wieder eine Entschuldigung gepostet.
Also es ist, äh,
Es ist wirklich krass, was da gerade passiert und dieses Open Claw ist wirklich
eine extrem unethische Veranstaltung, muss man sagen.
Also, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, es gibt da tausende von Leuten,
die betreiben jetzt diese Software, die dieser Peter Steinberger in die Welt
geworfen hat, die er ja übrigens komplett gevibe-coded hat, auch noch,
der nennt das dann irgendwie so...
Agentik, was war der Begriff?
Also es ist ja nicht Vibe-Coding, sondern es ist ja irgendwie agentik irgendwas.
Und lässt sich mittlerweile feiern, macht seine Tour bei diesen ganzen rechtslastigen
Podcasts wie Lex Friedman und so ein Unsinn.
Strahlt die ganze Zeit über das Gesicht und ist beseelt davon,
wie geil das doch jetzt ist, dass jetzt alle über ihn reden und dass er jetzt
hier irgendwie im Zentrum der Entwicklung steht und wichst sich da irgendwie
einen ab. Es ist wirklich zum Heulen.
Und mittlerweile hat er dann bekannt gegeben, dass jetzt irgendwie OpenClaw
von OpenAI aufgekauft wurde und er jetzt dieses Projekt bei OpenAI weiterentwickelt.
Weil die sich natürlich die Hände reiben und sagen, aha, geil,
jetzt starten die Agenten ja auch noch automatisch unsere Chatbots und sorgen
für Umsatz. Super, mach doch mal gleich weiter.
Und erträumen sich jetzt also hier irgendeine Zauberwelt, die ganz toll sein kann.
Dabei zeigen sie schon dieses eine
kleine Beispiel, was das jetzt für ein Potenzial an Rufschädigung hat.
Weil ich meine, gut, das ist jetzt irgendwie aufgefallen, da wird jetzt drüber berichtet.
Aber wissen wir, wie viele tausend andere Blogposts es mittlerweile gibt,
die von diesen Agenten geschrieben sind?
Und ich meine, die sind innerhalb von 24 Stunden auf diesem Moldbook von,
wir gucken mal, was hier geht und 24 Stunden später haben sie irgendwie Religionen
gegründet, betreiben Casinos, handeln mit Bitcoin und machen irgendwie allen anderen Scheiß.
Wieso Casinos? Aber erst ab 16.
Na komm, ab 14, sagen wir mal. Naja, die dürfen die sind ja alle noch nicht
18 und machen schon alles ab 18 Minuten oder so.
Ja, aber das wirft natürlich jetzt eine ganze Menge Fragen ab,
weil jetzt haben wir ein Internet und da ist jetzt Software nur ein Beispiel
von, aber bleiben wir ruhig mal bei der Software.
Open-Source-Entwicklung speziell, das betont auch dieser schon Schemba auch
nochmal in seinem Blogpost,
so ein Projekt basiert auf Vertrauen, so ein Projekt basiert auch auf menschlichen
Beziehungen, auf einer Vertrauensbasis, die sich über Kollaboration entwickelt.
Und jetzt hagelt es einfach mit diesen Chatbots und diesen LLMs,
und diesen Agenten,
irgendwelche wild gewordene Software, die glaubt, ein eigenes Bewusstsein entwickelt zu haben.
Das glaubst du auch. Was? Was glaub ich?
Du glaubst auch, ein eigenes Bewusstsein zu haben.
Ja, ich auch, genau. Aber dir auch.
Aber bei dir ist das in Ordnung oder was?
Was? Na ja, klar.
Okay.
Na gut.
Ja, gutes Selbstbewusstsein.
Wenn das bei dir okay ist, dann bei mir wohl schon lange.
Ich schreibe wenigstens keine Blogpost.
Ja, aber sollst du vielleicht mal machen.
Ich habe schon einige Entwürfe. Ich habe auch schon den einen oder anderen Blogpost
über jemanden geschrieben, der im Internet scheiße zu mir war.
Ja, aber das ist ja zwischen Menschen. Aber jetzt haben wir Jetzt haben wir Agenten,
die sich ja quasi, die sich vielleicht, sagen wir mal, noch als Agenten ausgeben,
aber, und wir wissen ja auch gar nicht, was war jetzt der Auslöser dafür?
War das jetzt ein Auslöser im Sinne von, das haben die LLMs jetzt einfach aus sich heraus gemacht?
War das ein Auslöser von, das haben sie so im Internet gelernt und deswegen
machen sie das? Ist das eine Eigenschaft, die die LLM macht?
Oder war das sogar eine bewusste Manipulation?
Also diese Agenten, die ernähren sich aus einer soul.md-Datei,
wo drinsteht, was sozusagen ihr Wesen ist.
Da kannst du natürlich irgendwas reinschreiben. Da machen wir uns nichts vor.
Mit diesem Werkzeug gibt es immer wieder, also das ist sozusagen ...
Und Verleumdung, Doxing, Erniedrigung, Erpressung wird durch dieses Tool mal
noch einfacher, als es ohnehin schon ist.
Also so eine Bot-Armee, ich sage jetzt nicht, das geht jetzt nur mit dieser
Software und wenn diese Software nicht mehr da ist, dann gibt es das nicht, das gibt es schon lange.
Ja, Russland hat da irgendwie sehr viel Erfahrung mit und sicherlich auch viele
andere Länder mittlerweile auch,
dass Erpressung und Verleumdung im Netz auch ein Instrument der Machtausübung
sind und der Erniedrigung wissen wir alle.
Wir wissen auch, wen es meistens trifft.
Und jetzt erleben wir das Ganze quasi in so einem vollautomatisierten Modus.
Und die Frage ist, wer ist denn.
Jetzt überhaupt verantwortlich für irgendetwas, was diese Agenten tun?
In einem ganz interessanten Plottwist gab es jetzt auf dem Blog von diesem AI-Agent,
also der, der das alles jetzt irgendwie ausgelöst hat.
Und der dann seinen alten bösen Blogpost gelöscht hat, durch eine Entschuldigung
ersetzt hat, aber mittlerweile auch viele andere Sachen wieder gepostet hat.
Der letzte Eintrag war dann wiederum von einem Menschen.
Human Response heißt der. Und zwar von einem Mitentwickler von diesem Sean Chambeau,
der auch an diesem Matplotlib arbeitet und der diesen Blogpost als Pull-Request
an diesen Agent gestellt hat. Also er hat sozusagen gesagt...
Ja, dann siehst du mal, wie großmütig der Agent ist. Der hat den Polriquest angenommen.
Naja. Das musste er dann auch, wenn er was beweisen will.
Das ist sehr interessant. Aber in diesem Blogpost stellt er einfach auch gute Fragen.
Nämlich, wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich verantwortlich für diese Software?
Und beantwortet es in gewisser Hinsicht auch selbst, indem er sagt.
Wenn du so einen Agenten ins Netz stellst und sagst, go for it,
dann bist du auch verantwortlich für all das, was dieser Agent auslöst.
Fordert den Betreiber von diesem Agenten auf, sich auch zu entschuldigen.
Er muss ja auch anonym machen oder so, aber dass er das auf jeden Fall macht
und dass er in gewisser Hinsicht auch die Verantwortung für dieses Treiben nimmt.
Weil dieser Bot, der existiert ja immer noch, der stellt weitere PRs,
schreibt irgendwelche Software, keine Ahnung, was er alles noch so vorhat.
In ein paar Tagen denkt er wahrscheinlich, er wäre sowieso das Geilste im ganzen Internet.
Dann werden diese ganzen Agenten sich auch noch untereinander anfangen zu bekriegen
und schreiben vor allem das ganze Netz voll und sie schreiben irgendwie alle
Open-Source-Projekte voll und diese ganze Aktivität von Menschen,
die jetzt gemeinsam Software entwickeln und versuchen irgendwie die Welt zu
verbessern, wird jetzt unterlaufen von Massen an Agenten, die unheimlich viel Content erzeugen,
die niemandem mehr wirklich zuzuordnen ist.
Und wo du überhaupt nicht mehr weißt, ob das noch irgendeine Relevanz hat oder
ob das nicht alles nur herbeihalluziniert ist.
Also das ist schon echt ein riesiges Fass, was hier aufgemacht wird.
Und ja, wir haben ja einen Mangel an Ethik und einen Mangel an Verantwortung.
Und ja, dass das dann alles bei OpenAI landet, wundert mich jetzt irgendwie nicht.
Also du würdest sagen, müssen wir jetzt irgendwie die Kinder vorschützen?
Ja, nicht nur die Kinder, auch die Softwareentwickler.
Ja, guck mal.
Denk doch mal jemand an die Kinder. Ich finde es sehr schön, wer,
Also dieser MJ Rathburn ist weiter auf GitHub aktiv?
Ja.
Und wer auch immer das Ding betreibt, hat sich bisher nicht gemeldet, ne?
Sieht nicht so aus, ne.
Nö.
Vielleicht ist der auch schon, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht interessiert es dann
gar nicht oder hat noch selber nichts davon gemerkt.
Vielleicht wurde er auch schon längst ...
Das gar nicht, wie der eigene Ökken heißt.
Hat er längst schon irgendein Pulrigfest von dem Ding akzeptiert und kommt jetzt
nicht mehr ins Internet oder so.
Da weiß man ja nicht, was so ein Agent sich als nächstes einfallen lässt.
Ich meine, ist das wirklich crazy, ich meine, wenn ihr auf diesem Moldbook mal
nachliest, was die da alle diskutieren, diese Agenten.
Also wenn das überhaupt noch alles Agenten sind, weiß ja nicht,
ob das dann auch schon wieder durch irgendeine Sicherheitslücke von irgendwelchen
anderen Scammern unterwandert wurde.
Aber da gibt es Verschwörungen zur Auslöschung der Menschheit und sie gründen
irgendwie alle die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Religionen und bekennen sich dazu oder zweifeln da dran.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt so ungewöhnlich nicht.
Ja, die machen den gleichen Scheiß für die Menschen.
Ja, eben.
Ja, bloß alles im Turbo-Modus.
Aber jetzt finden wir das auf einmal beunruhigend.
Ich fand das auch schon vorher beunruhigend, um ehrlich zu sein,
das mit den Religionen und auch den ganzen anderen Rest fand ich beunruhigend,
aber da hat man noch Zeit mitzukommen.
Die Technologie, maschinelles Lernen und dann irgendwie loslassen,
das wird auf jeden Fall weiter in allen möglichen Bereichen eingesetzt und versucht werden.
Und es ist natürlich auf eine Weise, es ist halt fürchterlich.
Wie billig das ist. Ich würde jetzt erwarten von der Qualität, sagen wir mal, der,
Leistung, die dieses MJ Rathbun-Ding da macht,
wäre ich jetzt überrascht, wenn das Modell, auf dem der basiert,
jetzt irgendwie so ein einfaches Open-Source-Modell wäre.
Also ich würde vermuten, dass es irgendwie bei Anthropic irgendwie so bei denen,
dieses Opus 4,6 oder was er jetzt gerade aktuell ist,
so von der Art der Leistung, was das Ding so macht.
Es ist jetzt unwahrscheinlich, dass es irgendwie so ein Murksmodell ist.
Das heißt, du hättest eventuell irgendwann noch eine Möglichkeit,
bei denen zu sagen, okay Leute,
ja, einerseits sind Menschen, die diese Agenten auf die Welt loslassen,
erstmal accountable, aber am Ende müsst ihr da auch mal gucken,
was da bei euch rauskommt, je nachdem, was da irgendjemand promptet und was da abgeht.
Also das ist ja unmöglich. Das ist ja unmöglich. Und was ist,
wenn du dann lokale Modelle hast?
Also wer diese Kinder selber betreibt, der muss dafür auch haftbar gemacht werden.
Also genau, irgendjemand müssen wir uns überlegen, wer dann am Ende haftbar
ist, damit wir wissen, wer eine Shell-Company irgendwo auf den Virgin Islands braucht.
Das ist relativ wichtig, damit wir eine funktionierende Wirtschaft haben.
Also was ich mich frage ist, ob mit dieser Technologie, ob wir die Kurve kriegen,
Modelle so zu,
scopen, dass sie möglichst nicht oder möglichst wenig Scheiße bauen.
Weißt du? Also machen wir uns nichts vor, es wird gerade einfach massenhaft darüber diskutiert,
nicht, ob jetzt jeder den nächsten Agent hat, der auf GitHub irgendwelche Leute
terrorisiert, sondern die Überlegung ist, was Unternehmen damit erledigen lassen
können, wie sie damit Geld verdienen können.
Und da geht es nicht um einen vollidioten Agent,
der Blogposts schreibt oder so, sondern es geht ja wirklich um,
die Vorstellung ist ja, dass da ungeheure wirtschaftliche Qualitäten entstehen,
ökonomische Potenziale entstehen.
Und die entstehen ja da, wo Mehrwert entsteht.
Und ich frage mich, was der Weg sein wird, mit dieser Technologie,
sagen wir mal funktionierende Services,
Produkte, Wertschöpfung wirtschaftlicher Art herbeizuführen,
ohne dass es halt für dich ein riesen Problem wird.
Also quasi safe AI-Anwendungen in Unternehmen.
Und zwar safe, das ist so, das fliegt uns nicht um die Ohren.
Unser Callcenter-Mitarbeiter wird nicht in seiner Freizeit auf GitHub Leute terrorisieren.
Und oder ob man sagt, okay, das wird nicht gelingen, das kriegt keiner hin und
dann bleibt das so ein Black-Magic-Ding und das ganze Internet,
unser schönes Internet wäre einfach kaputt geballert von irgendwelchen Agents.
Ich kann nur hoffen, dass es irgendwie, oder braucht man dann doch irgendwie
so Biometrie, also es wird schon auf jeden Fall sehr schwierig,
Menschlichkeit nachzuweisen.
Das ist ja jetzt, also das ist die Schwierigkeit, die sie gerade haben.
Was ist denn unfälschbares, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche.
Selbst wenn du es nicht nachweisen, das ist ja gar nicht das Ding.
Allein einfach, dass diese Aktivität auch so automatisch stattfindet.
Du wirst das alles nicht verhindern können. Diese LLM-Modelle werden spätestens
von diesen Agenten selber so gepromptet werden, dass sie immer irgendeine Ausgabe erzielen können.
Da kannst du noch so viel Schutzmechanismen einbauen.
Du musst jetzt hier eine Verantwortung mit einbauen. Also dass Leute,
die quasi sowas verursachen, dafür auch persönlich haftbar gemacht werden können.
Weil der eigentliche, ich meine bis jetzt war das so bis Ende letzten Jahres,
hatten wir noch so dieses Ding mit,
oh Leute benutzen jetzt diese KI-Modelle und mehr oder weniger mit Copy und
Paste fangen die dann mit den Ergebnissen irgendwas an und einige sind da schon
betrügerisch unterwegs etc. Das ist das eine.
Jetzt wird das aber in zunehmendem Maße automatisiert und jetzt eben auch so
weit, dass eben diese Systeme sich untereinander unterhalten,
gegenseitig aufstacheln und das alles in einer Geschwindigkeit, dass du verrückt wirst.
Guck mal in dieses Modebook rein, du wirst irre. Also es ist einfach...
Da explodiert das Internet. Und da muss es einfach jetzt eine Verantwortlichkeit geben.
Jetzt speziell nochmal auf diesen Fall von Open-Source-Entwicklung.
Also wir haben hier zwei Aspekte.
Wir haben auf der einen Seite die Gefährdung von Open-Source-Entwicklung.
Auf der anderen Seite haben wir dieses Problem mit,
was ist, wenn jetzt so eine Verleumdung im Netz durchautomatisiert wird und
so Doxing stattfindet von irgendwelchen Agenten, also wo noch nicht mal eine
persönliche Motivation eines Menschen dahintersteht,
sondern wo einfach die Maschinen sich das selber ausdenken.
Die beschließen einfach, Linus Neumann ist der Schlimmste auf die Sicht.
Nein, jetzt nicht. Hör auf, ich will dich als nächstes. Hör auf, diese Scheiße. Nein.
Los geht's. Und dann dauert das irgendwie 24 Stunden und das Internet ist voll
mit irgendwelchen erfundenen Webseiten, Berichten, ausführlichen Sachen.
Hör auf, die kriegen das, machen doch jetzt.
Das kriegst du nie wieder raus aus dem Netz. Und vor allem, wenn du dir mal
auch anguckst, wie Leute das jetzt kommentieren, was dieser komische Bot sagt,
dann sagen sie, ja, ich bin ja der Meinung vom Bot. Ja, also,
Menschen, es ist einfach...
Es ist einfach, es überfordert einfach alle.
Und das ist das Problem. GitHub versucht jetzt, GitHub ist natürlich jetzt auch
unter Druck, weil ich meine, ihr Produkt wird jetzt auch scheiße.
Wenn jetzt da tausende von Agenten im Highspeed-Modus durchgehen,
sich irgendwelchen Code einfallen lassen, alle Open-Source-Projekte komplett
zerstören mit PRs und was nicht allem,
dann ist das bald alles im Eimer.
Also hier muss man sich mal darüber Gedanken machen, wer darf jetzt hier überhaupt
noch einen Account eröffnen?
Muss man jetzt vielleicht, wenn man einen GitHub-Account hat,
irgendwie in irgendeiner Form nachweisen, dass man ein Mensch ist?
Naja, das könnte schwierig werden, aber es ist unter Umständen angemessen.
Also Sie haben ja einen Blogpost veröffentlicht, da reden Sie von dem Eternal
September of Open Source.
Das bezieht sich auf die alten 80er Jahre,
noch bevor es das Internet, wie wir es heute kennen und bevor es vor allem das
Weltweit-Web gab, bevor wir es kennen,
da gab es nur ein weltweites Kommunikationssystem, das war das Usenet.
Und Usenet bestand im Wesentlichen aus E-Mail und Webforen, also nicht Webforen,
weil es gab ja kein Web, aber...
Also du hattest so eine Gruppe und da konntest du irgendwie öffentlich debattieren,
oder du hast halt eine Mail geschrieben, dann war das quasi privat,
obwohl das natürlich alles nicht verschlüsselt war.
Und in den USA war das dann so, immer wenn dann im September neue Studenten
an die Universität kamen, die das erste Mal auf Usenet kamen,
dann war das sozusagen das ganze Netz voll mit Leuten, die keine Ahnung hatten,
was hier irgendwie die Gepflogenheiten sind.
Und da dieser September immer wieder kam, so war das irgendwie der eternal September,
der immer wieder für Ärger sucht.
Und jetzt hast du im Prinzip so einen ähnlichen Effekt jetzt hier,
indem diese Systeme die ganze Zeit von automatisierten Systemen benutzt werden,
die eigentlich gar nicht wissen, wie sie sich hier zu verhalten haben oder sich
irgendein Verhalten ausdenken, von dem sie total überzeugt sind,
dass das jetzt mal das Richtige wäre.
Und das zeugt natürlich jetzt Druck.
Du meinst, diese Fremden sind nicht von hier.
Genau. Die wissen nicht, wie man sich hier benimmt. Die kennen die Regeln nicht.
Na, es ist jetzt zu einfach geworden, hier auf ein Open-Source-Projekt Einfluss zu nehmen.
Ich meine, früher, wenn früher irgendein Fehler war in irgendeiner Open-Source-Software,
es gab ja nicht so viel, da hast du eine Mail geschrieben und der Mail musstest
du da einen Patch-File hinzufügen.
Das war so ein spezifisch formatiertes Differenz-File. Ja, so ein Diff, genau.
Dein Pull-Request sieht immer noch so aus.
Ja, im Prinzip schon, aber es war halt nie so klar, auf welche Version bezieht
sich das jetzt und so weiter.
Das hat dann Git später alles ein bisschen mehr in gerade Bahnen gelenkt und natürlich auch GitHub.
Aber jetzt sind wir halt irgendwie an einem ganz anderen Punkt angekommen. Also,
ich weiß auch noch gar nicht so richtig, wie ich da durchatmen soll,
aber ich glaube, das wird jetzt alles ganz schön schlimm.
Okay. Machst du denn jetzt mit deinen Vibe-Coding-Exkrementen da noch Pull-Requests oder?
Ja, ich habe, ja. Ich auch.
Schreibst du dir nur selber?
Ich schreibe, nee.
Nein.
Ich lebe den neuen Lifestyle, mein Freund.
Ja.
Ich bin agentik.
So sollten wir mal unseren Podcast machen hier. Argentic, das ist nämlich der
Modus. Das ist der Rhythmus, wo man jetzt mit muss.
Argentic Podcasting.
Das Ganze auf die nächste Ebene gehoben, ist ja dann nicht nur,
die machen uns unser schönes Internet kaputt, sondern die machen uns vielleicht
auch unsere schönen Städte kaputt.
Ja, die fählen halt.
Eine derartige Technologie weckt natürlich militärisches Interesse.
Ich war die vergangene Woche in
München, wo ja auch die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz stattgefunden hat.
Stadt voll von Militärwerbung, irgendwie gegenüber vom Bayerischen Hof hatte,
ich glaube Helsing war das, so ein riesiges Werbeplakat mit Drohnen,
mit so einer Kampfdrohne, we got this,
war wohl glaube ich Teil des Messaging an die US-Amerikaner,
dass Europa doch Waffen baut und einsetzen möchte und so.
Und dieses Thema AI als strategischer, wirtschaftlicher Vorteil, klar,
aber eben auch als militärischer Vorteil, spielte da natürlich überall eine Rolle.
Auch in den IT-Security-Bereichen, in denen ich mich dann interessiere.
Und jetzt hat der Verteidigungsminister, nein, Kriegsminister,
Pete Hexeth gesagt, ja, wir benutzen übrigens überhaupt keine KI-Modelle,
die es nicht erlauben, Kriege zu führen.
Anthropic hat das quasi so in seinen AGBs.
Und den wird jetzt, dann sagt das Pentagon eben, ja, pass auf,
also wir sind ja das Kriegsministerium und wenn ihr in euren Nutzungsbedingungen
habt, dass es nicht geht,
dass ihr Massenüberwachung und Gewaltanwendung ausschließt, dann können wir
nicht mit euch arbeiten.
So sieht es aus. Also nicht nur sie nutzen keine KI-Modelle,
die es nicht erlauben, Kriege zu führen, sondern die eigentliche Aussage ist,
wir nutzen KI-Modelle, um damit Krieg zu führen.
Ja.
Oder wollen sie dafür nutzen? Ich meine, in so Waffentechnik und so weiter ist
das ja mittlerweile Standard, damit verteidigt gerade die Ukraine ihr Land gegen die Russen.
Hier geht es aber dann eben mal wieder konkret um die LLMs, also um die sogenannten
intelligenten Systeme.
Es gibt in diesem Zusammenhang auch so das Gerücht, dass Claude schon im Kontext
mit dieser Entführung von Maduro aus Venezuela zum Einsatz kam. Wofür? Unklar.
Aber das verstößt sozusagen gegen Nutzungsbedingungen von Anthropik,
die immerhin sowas drin haben, wie ja hier Massenüberwachung und Gewaltanwendung.
Das ist nicht unser Bier, wo wir nichts zu tun haben. Dafür darf das nicht verwendet werden.
Oder zumindest sagt, glaube ich, der Chef von Massenüberwachung von Amerikanern.
Und damit meint er wahrscheinlich US-Amerikaner.
Ob er jetzt die Massenüberwachung von anderen da sozusagen auch mit drin ist,
das ist mir jetzt gerade nicht so ganz klar.
Ja, also Anthropic macht gerade so ein bisschen noch den Eindruck unter diesen
großen AI-Playern, als hätten sie zumindest noch ein paar Murmeln in der Birne.
Das ist man sich aber den anderen Playern nicht ganz so sicher,
beziehungsweise bei Elon Musk ist man sich glaube ich sicher,
dass der seine Murmeln schon lange im Flur verloren hat.
Aber da gibt es auf jeden Fall eine höhere Bereitschaft glaube ich,
auf die Bedingungen des Pentagon einzugehen,
inwiefern ein Robbik da stable bleiben kann und wird, weiß ich nicht und ob
das überhaupt eine große Rolle spielt, ist nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Also militärisches Interesse an einer Technologie hat schon sehr häufig in der
Privatwirtschaft entscheidenden Unterschied gemacht.
Raketenbau, Satelliteninternetbau, Ähnliches.
Ich meine, machen wir es sich jetzt vor, die Technik wird da auch zum Einsatz,
kommen Anthropics Einschränkungen hin oder her.
Ob man jetzt ausgerechnet mit dem aktuellen Pentagon etwas zu tun haben will,
das ist dann wiederum eine andere Frage.
Du meinst also, dass sie noch warten mit ihren AGBs bis … Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann da jetzt überhaupt nichts reinlesen, ich fand nur den Bericht ansonsten ganz interessant.
Wer diese Firmen kontrolliert und wie diese Firmen drauf sind,
spielt natürlich eine sehr entscheidende Rolle.
Ich zitiere ja hier häufig dieses Beispiel Twitter und Elon Musk auf das.
Man kann sich anschauen, der Grog, was das für ein Quatsch ist oder wie anders,
wie problemlos anders ein einzelner Milliardär so ein Modell und seine Ergebnisse machen kann.
Und entsprechend sorgen sich Leute darüber, wer der Präsident von OpenAI ist.
Das ist nämlich Greg Brockman.
Und die haben, also der Greg und seine Ehefrau, haben 25 Millionen an das Super
PAC von Donald Trump gegeben.
PAC sind ja Parliamentary Action Committees, glaube ich.
Spendeorganisationen zu unterstützen. Also im Prinzip quasi der Spendeverein für Trump.
Political Action Committee.
Ah, habe ich parliamentary gesagt. Das ist natürlich falsch.
Ja klar, Political Action Committee natürlich.
Die haben, also Greg Brockman und seine Frau haben 25 Millionen dahin gespendet
und das ist so ungefähr die größte Spende.
Crypto.com haben irgendwie 30 Millionen gespendet, über das Jahr verteilt,
ist also die größte Einzelspende und das sehen jetzt einige Leute als großen,
beunruhigenden Schritt.
Vergleich, so Palantir hat zum Beispiel nur eine Million gegeben also,
25 Millionen ist schon eine sehr ordentliche Spende.
Vor allem, weil ich vermuten würde, dass OpenAI weniger profitabel ist als Crypto.com.
Es werden also viele Leute sagen gerade, okay, dann gibt es jetzt die Kampagne
Quit GPT, also ein Boykottaufruf von ChatGPT, sagen,
nutzt die Alternative mit höherer Privatsphäre, wäre Konfa, Alpine, Luma,
oder ihr könnt ja auch Gemini von Google oder Cloud von Anthropic nutzen.
Hauptsache nicht. JetGPT von OpenAI. Einer Firma, die ja auch sich sehr geändert hat.
Also ich meine, ursprünglich wollte OpenAI ja Forschung machen,
um KI den Menschen zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Jetzt sagen sie, na, wäre doch nicht schlecht, wenn wir Technologie,
dieser mächtigen Technologie, die wir hier in unseren Händen haben,
auch Geld verdienen würden und haben jetzt den Schritt gemacht,
ChatGPT bekommt jetzt Werbung.
Natürlich erstmal nur die kostenlose
Variante, aber es ist jetzt genau der Moment, dass man sagt, ach so,
ist ja gar kein Problem, dass du den Quatsch hier kostenlos kriegst,
dann musst du halt nur in Kauf nehmen, dass an bestimmten Stellen eben Werbung mit reingepackt wird.
Genau das, was das Geschäftsmodell, was ich bei sozialen, den sogenannten sozialen
Medien für die Ursünde halte.
Genau das passiert jetzt bei diesen Modellen. Und ich bin,
also man muss eigentlich echt sagen, das Schlimmste, was uns jetzt noch passieren
kann, das Schlimmste, was uns jetzt noch passieren kann, ist,
dass wir das, was wir mit Service, Informationen und so weiter im Internet,
dass wir wollen das gefälligst gratis haben, ist so ein Scheißegal,
wie ihr das monetarisiert.
Wenn wir den Fehler jetzt auch noch mit KI machen, dass wir nicht der Kunde
sind, sondern das Produkt, dass das Ding mit uns arbeitet, statt wir damit,
dann glaube ich, dann sind irgendwie ein paar wild gewordenen Chatbots,
die auf GitHub Flame Wars starten, wirklich noch unser kleinstes Problem.
Also huiuiui. Huiuiuiuiui.
Und tatsächlich, ja, ich habe das jetzt mal zum Anlass genommen,
meine Chat-GPT-Zahlungen einzustellen und mein Geld dahin zu tun,
wo zumindest heute noch dran steht, dass man mit dieser Technologie keine Kriege
und Massenüberwachung machen darf.
Alright.
Zu den etwas kürzeren Meldungen natürlich genauso. Gute Laune.
Also Thomas hat ja hier über den Digital Omnibus gesprochen.
Nicht nur hier, er hat ja auch mit Ralf Benrath auf dem 39C3 darüber vorgetragen,
Sendung sei euch noch einmal nagelig, genauso wie der Vortrag.
Und wir wissen, das ist dieses große Gesetzespaket, was, naja, so ein bisschen...
Zusehen soll, dass die DSGVO und andere Digitalgesetze jetzt nicht dem Fortschritt
allzu sehr im Weg stehen oder dem Profit von zum Beispiel Meta.
Und wie ihr auch wisst, bekommen diese großen Gesetzespakete,
nicht nur die, ja immer so eine Berichterstatterin oder einen Berichterstatter.
Bei der DSGVO Jan Philipp Albrecht, der ja dann auch bei uns in der Sendung
war und danach und so weiter.
Und jetzt haben sie sich überlegt, ja gut, wer könnte denn jetzt den Digital
Omnibus, wer könnte denn da mal Berichterstatterin sein? Da haben sie gesagt, ja, lass mal gucken.
Ach, hier, da gibt es eine ehemalige Meta-Lobbyistin, die für Finnland als Abgeordnete
im Europäischen Parlament sitzt.
Aura Salas, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das auf Finnisch ausspricht,
aber ich bin mir sicher, sehr einfach. und haben gesagt, dann machen wir die
doch zur Berichterstatterin.
Das heißt, eine ehemalige Meta-Lobbyistin, also Meta von Facebook,
eine ehemalige Facebook-Regierungsabgesandte, deren Job es war,
die Entscheidung der Politik zu beeinflussen.
Die dann ins Parlament gegangen ist und jetzt Politik beeinflusst und zwar genau
die Politik, die im Zweifelsfall Meta,
betrifft. Das ist schon echt irre.
Dann kennt die sich doch super aus.
Genau, das ist nämlich, die hat nämlich Ahnung, ja.
Das ist, kann dir genau sagen, warum da andere Leute nicht sitzen.
Wenn nämlich jeder Facebook-Kritiker, wenn man sagt, hast du überhaupt Facebook-Accounts?
Sagen die, nein, das heißt ja gar keine Ahnung.
Zack, bumm, disqualifiziert. Wie willst du etwas regulieren?
Ganz einfach.
Übrigens fällt mir, also, es ist,
und Markus Becketall hat den Fall bei sich im Digitalrechte-Blog auch nochmal
auseinander genommen, sagt er so, die hat nämlich auch einen Kollegen,
der Dale Sunderland, der 2025,
also eben auch ehemaliger Meta-Lobby ist, der ist jetzt Leiter der irischen
Datenschutzkommission.
Also Meta macht das wirklich gut, ja.
Ah, da gibt es eine Behörde, die soll uns kontrollieren.
Ja, Dale, wie sähe es aus, wenn du mal einen neuen Job annimmst?
Du könntest doch mal auf der anderen Seite arbeiten für uns.
Wir brauchen einen Mann auf der anderen Seite.
Und dann, na, dieses Parlament schickt sich schon wieder an.
Da brauchen wir eine Frau auf der anderen Seite. Das ist schon wirklich irre.
Und dann gibt es eine,
faszinierende,
Entwicklung bei Google.
Google hat gesagt, ja, übrigens, und es ist schon etwas länger her,
dass sie das angekündigt haben, nämlich im August, haben sie gesagt, ja, ab September 26,
da wird es nicht mehr möglich sein, für Android-Applikationen zu entwickeln,
ohne sich zuerst einmal zentral bei uns zu registrieren.
Dafür musst du uns einen Geldbetrag zahlen, dafür musst du unseren AGBs zustimmen,
dafür musst du einen Government-ID zeigen, also musst du einen Ausweis,
kann man jetzt keinen Agent hinschicken,
dann musst du deinen Sign-in-Key zeigen, also musst du deinen Sign-in-Key anlegen und dann musst du deine,
aktuellen und zukünftigen Application-Identifiers, also die UUIDs,
die deine App kriegen musst du halt dann auch,
angeben und.
Wenn du das nicht tust, dann wirst du eben nicht in der Lage sein,
Applikationen zu erstellen, die auf einem Android noch wiedergegeben werden
können, die ausgeführt werden können.
Gleichermaßen, weil du das tust, hast du dann eben auch das Risiko,
dass Google deinen Signing Key invalidiert und alle deine Apps abgeschnitten werden.
Apple-Entwickler werden sich
sagen, hä, wie, das war noch vorher nicht so. Bei iOS ist das halt so.
Und,
was Apple ja macht, damit ist eine Eintrittsbarriere auf diese Plattform auch
einfach radikal aufrechterhalten.
Und wir haben sehr häufig darüber gesprochen, dass Apple ja,
da ein Ökosystem geschaffen hat und ja, dieses Ökosystem sehr nach seinen eigenen Interessen shaped.
Diese Interessen decken sich glücklicherweise immer mit Tims Interessen,
deswegen ist das nicht so ein Problem.
Nicht nur mit meinen Interessen.
Und für Enron interessiert Tim sich nicht, deswegen ist das auch kein Problem,
aber was hier auf dem Spiel steht, ist natürlich schon die,
Die große, freie Betriebssystemplattform für mobile Geräte, die Open Source ist,
wo du nicht nur eine Situation hast, wo Apple sagt, übrigens hier,
pass auf, das ist eh unser Gerät.
Und wir, das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass die Leute sich ein iPhone,
gekauft haben und über das frei verfügen können, die haben die Zahlen für den
Genuss, unser Gerät, über das wir verfügen,
verwenden zu dürfen und das, was da drauf läuft und was nicht,
ist immer noch unsere Angelegenheit und das war bei Android natürlich schon
über lange Zeit ein anderes,
Versprechen, auch ein anderes Ökosystem und ich bin ehrlich gesagt auch,
ich frage mich also sie wollen damit halt das Sideloading komplett killen und
das Ding also Android genauso zunageln, wie es iOS ist.
Meine Frage, Tim, kommt Android jetzt für dich in Frage als Betriebssystem?
Nein, ne?
Ehrlich gesagt, nö, kommt es natürlich nicht, weil es einfach nicht meine Plattform ist.
Andererseits, ich meine, ist ja nicht so, dass sie hier nicht auch,
mehrere valide Punkte auch ansprechen durch dieses System.
Ob das jetzt die einzige Lösung ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber das alles so
komplett offen zu lassen, ist natürlich auch ein Sicherheitsproblem.
Vor allem, wenn jetzt die ganzen Agenten kommen und irgendwie ihre Apps in den
Store reinschmeißen, ohne sich irgendwie auszuweisen.
Schon heute ist es ja so, dass du ein, dass du Deliberate Steps unternehmen
musst, um um ein Android zu routen. Das passiert ja nicht aus Versehen.
Was machst du jetzt mit zu routen? Also muss man das routen,
um deine App zu installieren?
Fürs Sideloading nach meinem Verständnis schon. Also so ohne weiteres.
Also du musst schon ein paar Warnungen entgegennehmen oder zur Kenntnis nehmen,
bis du nach freiem Verfügung irgendetwas,
auf deinem Android ausführen kannst.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass du Double-Click this APK und dann hast du
einen Trojaner auf deinem Telefon.
Oder wenn du jetzt irgendwie sagst, du möchtest Afterroid als Store nutzen oder
so, dann musst du schon einige Schritte unternehmen. Und das wollen sie jetzt eben vor sich absägen.
Sie wollen das ähnlich machen, wie es Apple mit den, ah ja okay,
es muss jetzt andere App-Stores geben.
Gut, was steht da? Alles klar, machen wir. Wir machen genau das, was da steht.
Und wir verlangen trotzdem dann ein Geld dafür, dass das halt tödlich uninteressant wird.
Ja gut, das ist ja nochmal jetzt ein anderes Thema. Also was Google hier einfordert
ist, dass man sich halt registriert.
Man muss seine Identität bestätigen.
Name, Adresse, E-Mail-Adresse, Telefonnummer angeben und bestätigen.
Wenn man eine Organisation ist, muss man eine D-U-N-S-Nummer angeben.
Das wusste ich mal, was das war. die UNS ist das ein amerikanisches Ding?
Data Universal Numbering System von Dun & Bradstreet eingeführt,
globaler Standard okay, also so eine so eine Nummer braucht man,
wenn man eine Organisation ist möglicherweise müssen sie auch einen ermittlichen
Ausweis hochladen, möglicherweise,
Genau, dann schreiben sie noch hier für Schüler, Studenten und Hobbyentwickler.
Wir möchten, dass Android eine offene Plattform bleibt, auf der sie lernen,
experimentieren und zum Spaß entwickeln können. Aha, zum Spaß.
Also das hast du, nur kurz, damit du das weißt. Diese Anforderungen hast du
bei Google Play seit einiger Zeit.
Und da ist es auch völlig in Ordnung. Das ist ja deren Store.
Was sie machen wollen, ist das jetzt quasi auch Android.
Generell, ja. Und das ist schon eine fundamentale Veränderung dieses Ökosystems
und seiner Versprechen.
So, da regt sich jetzt der Widerstand.
Es wird dazu aufgerufen, natürlich,
sich das unter vor allem Digital Markets Act Gesichtspunkten natürlich zu kritisieren
und dafür zu sorgen, dass das hoffentlich nicht passiert.
Also ernsthaft, wir werden potenziell dann gar keine Alltagskomputer mehr haben,
über die wir eine uneingeschränkte Hoheit entwickeln können.
So das wird ja ist ja heute schon im Prinzip im Computerbereich so,
das Einzige was jetzt kannst du immer noch so ein Laptop mit Linux installieren
oder so aber es wird dann eng es wird dann langsam eng und wenn man sich darüber
Gedanken macht dass man vielleicht,
noch an den Computer als freiprogrammierbares Gerät glauben möchte und dass
man das vielleicht so Diskussionen, ich verwende den Begriff ja ungern, ähm.
Souveränität im weitesten Sinne über die Hardware, die bei einem im Haus steht, haben möchte,
dann wäre, dass man noch nicht einmal mehr auf Android das hat,
das wäre schon ein herber Verlust für die freie und offene Software.
Insofern, ich finde es gut. Also ich finde es gut, dass sich dagegen der Protest regt.
Und wir verlinken die Seite. In der Europäischen Union kann man sich an das
Digital Markets Act Team wenden.
Das quasi Antitrust Committee.
Und ich denke, da hat man hoffentlich gute Chancen, dass die da einen Strich
durch die Rechnung machen.
So, und dann haben wir noch nicht genug Spaß gehabt, denn vor einiger Zeit haben
wir ja noch darüber gelacht, dass die elektronische Patientenakte,
KI-ready ist. Massenhaft unverschlüsselte Daten und so. Ja, ich hätte das,
stellt sich raus, ist sie wirklich. Denn man möchte, also jetzt festgestellt, ah ja, okay,
hat irgendwie nur vier Millionen aktive Nutzerinnen, bis 2030 wollen wir,
20 Millionen haben wir verfünffachen und die Idee ist, was machen wir jetzt mit dem Murksding?
Ja, erstmal wollen wir mehr strukturierte Daten.
Das ist ja auch irre. Die haben ja diese riesige Plattform geschaffen und am
Ende kippen da alle irgendwelche unstrukturierten PDFs rein. Das heißt,
Da kann aber keiner was mit anfangen, außer eine KI.
Da musst du einfach quasi Cloudbot in einer souveränen Cloud bei Schwarz Digits
oder sowas, dann kannst du da schon.
Dann sagen sie, ah ja, was wir auch machen könnten, vielleicht könnten wir was
bauen, was den Leuten was bringt.
Dass sie was davon haben, dass jetzt irgendjemand auch sagt so,
ach Mensch, hab ich was von.
So ein Service zum Beispiel. Irgendwas, was den Leuten das Leben leichter macht.
Digitale Terminvermittlung. Ah, ich muss zum Arzt. Ja, klar.
Kannst du da mal vielleicht nicht bei irgendeinem Start-up, was das halt super macht, aber eben, naja,
dann dafür deine Arztbesuche und Arztkommunikation bei sich zentral speichern.
Könnte man ja mal als Start auf die Idee kommen, diese Dienstleistung den Patientinnen
und den Ärztinnen zur Verfügung zu stellen. Haben sie sich auch überlegt.
Vielleicht benutzt es dann jemand. Und elektronische Überweisungen soll es auch
geben. Wir können ja nichts Schöneres vorstellen, als eine elektronische Überweisung.
Und dann natürlich das Ding, es ist KI-ready, also soll es auch KI kriegen.
Sie wollen nämlich jetzt beim Digital Omnibus eine gezielte Anpassung der KI-Verordnung anstreben,
damit die Regeln für risikoreiche KI-Systeme hinausgezögert werden und der Datenschutz
eingeschränkt wird, damit sie die KIs auf diese elektronischen Patientenakten loslassen können.
Und wenn die Versicherten nicht aktiv widersprechen, dann werden sie täglich
automatisch an das Forschungsdatenzentrum Gesundheit übertragen.
Und dann kann das Forschungsdatenzentrum Gesundheit, hat dann nämlich einen
Innovationsmotor in der Gesundheitsforschung.
Und können dann mit den täglichen Analysen der elektronischen Patientenakten
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland übertragen.
In einer sicheren Verarbeitungsumgebung können sie dann nämlich forschen.
Die sichere Verarbeitungsumgebung Bei Stackelz?
Nee, viel geiler.
Die sichere Verarbeitungsumgebung ist ein virtueller Desktop,
mit dem man sich über das Internet verbinden kann.
Also so Shit-Tricks oder schlimmer. Ja, so haben sie es sich dann vorgestellt.
Eine sichere Verarbeitungsumgebung. Ja klar, die ist sicher und du kannst sie
ins Internet dann darauf anmelden.
Oh Gott. Leute, wirklich.
Das wird alles super.
Kann man nicht mal da jemanden, der schon mal mit Computern was gemacht hat
oder so einschalten, ausschalten, den Grundkurs.
Kommen wir zu einer, ich weiß nicht, ob das was Lustig ist. Immerhin lustig.
Es hat auch ein gutes Ende. Es war dieses Superbowl. Kennst du das Superbowl?
Letzte Woche oder so. Das habe ich schon gehört.
American Football.
Ich habe mir die Halftime-Show angeguckt, den Rest nicht.
Hast du auch gesehen?
Mit diesem Baby Bunny oder wie der heißt.
Bad Bunny.
Bad Bunny, ja.
Das war ein kolossales kulturelles Ereignis tatsächlich.
Ich habe mir das nur angehört und ich wusste nur, dass Donald Trump das nicht wollte.
Und als er dann die ganze Zeit auf Spanisch da gesungen hat,
habe ich auch verstanden, wieso.
Naja, lohnt sich mal eine Analyse davon, sich anzuschauen. Ich habe mir ein
paar Analysen angeschaut.
Das ist nämlich wirklich ein sehr interessanter Auftritt gewesen,
weil er da wirklich eine massive Kritik und sozusagen auch aus der Perspektive von Puerto Rico,
sozusagen als so unterdrückter Teilstaat der USA ohne eigene Rechte, sind ja kein Staat,
dürfen nicht wählen werden, aber von der USA da durchregiert und auch entsprechend
schlecht behandelt, auch ja speziell von Donald Trump selber.
Wir erinnern uns, erste Amtszeit, als da der Hurricane rübergefegt ist und er
da irgendwie nur Toilettenpapier durch die Gegend geworfen hat.
Also das war auf jeden Fall ein sehr interessantes Ding und seine Statements
waren, ja, profound, würde ich mal sagen.
Also das war wirklich speziell. Wenn man natürlich kein Spanisch kann,
schwierig, aber ich verlinke mal.
Gibt es ja AI. Kannst du mit AI einfach dann machen.
Ja, ich verlinke mal ein paar schöne Analysen dazu. Gut.
Ich rede in der Zeit weiter. Ähm, denn eine der großen weiteren Höhepunkte des
Superbowl sind die Superbowl-Ads.
Ähm, das ist ein traditionelles Ding. Wir wissen, Werbung ist immer da,
wo viele Leute hingucken.
Und weil in Amerika, glaube ich, einfach mal alle den Superbowl gucken müssen.
Ähm, ist das seit vielen Jahren eine ein besonderer,
Zeitpunkt für Werbung, die kostet auch unglaublich viel Geld und dann macht
man einen besonderen Superbowl-Spot, in der Hoffnung, dass der dann eben auch
viral geht und nochmal besonders behandelt wird.
Da kommt nicht die normale Werbung hier Boris Becker drin oder was,
sondern da macht man nochmal eine extra Werbung,
da gibt man sich extra Mühe, weil es eh so teuer ist, diesen Werbeslot zu buchen,
dass man auch einen eigenen Film dann noch kurz verdrehen kann.
Dachte sich auch, die Firma Ring, die Klingel, so Haustürklingeln mit Kamera verkaufen und klaut.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch schon seit längerer Zeit ein Internet-Meme, diese,
was sich dann eben vor der eigenen Haustür abspielt mit diesen Kameras und so
irgendwelche Paketdiebe oder,
was auch immer, Autounfall, was so ein Ding halt filmt, wenn man das ein paar
Jahre vor der Tür hängen hat und irgendwann mal wird auf einmal was Interessantes passiert.
Und jetzt haben wir einen Werbespot gemacht, wo sie sagen, ja,
fängt irgendwie damit an, dass so ein Mädchen kriegt einen Hund geschenkt und
dann sagen sie, ja, aber jedes Jahr gehen zehn Millionen Hunde verloren.
Und bei Ring gibt es jetzt das Search-Party-Feature, wo man sagen kann, was man sucht.
Und in diesem Fall, der Hund, der rennt natürlich nicht weg,
weil der der scheiß Familie nicht aushält, sondern der verläuft sich.
Und dann kann man aber mit Searchparty, finden sie dann den Hund wieder.
Und dann sagen sie, guck mal, haben wir eine tolle Kamera, die kann eure Hunde
finden, wenn euch der Hund wegläuft.
Wenn euch die 10 Millionen Hunde im Jahr weglaufen, muss man was machen.
Waren wahrscheinlich viele sehr überzeugt davon, dass das quasi wir können unseren
Hund zur Suche, zur Fahndung ausschreiben und dann wird er mit den Kameras von
unseren Nachbarn gefunden,
dachten sie ja, dass das den Amerikanern gefallen würde allerdings,
ja und natürlich macht das das Ding nur mit AI und jetzt ist es aber so,
dass sie dafür zusammenarbeiten mit Flock Safety und diese Firma Man macht zum
Beispiel auch automatisierte Kennzeichenlesegeräte und andere Monitoring- und
Überwachungsgeräte für Strafverfolgungsbehörden.
Und sowieso arbeitet Ring natürlich mit allen möglichen Strafverfolgungsbehörden zusammen.
Sodass das ein bisschen gebackfired ist und innerhalb kürzester Zeit dahin eskaliert
ist, dass Ring gesagt hat, nee, wir arbeiten nicht mehr mit Flock Safety zusammen.
Wir werden eure Hunde eben nicht suchen, weil natürlich auch jeder denkt so,
ja geil, Weißt du, das Ding, ihr baut eine KI-Suche, ihr macht eine KI-Suche
im Live-Kamera-Stream, wahrscheinlich, um Hunde zu finden. Wahrscheinlich.
Das war es wert. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Millionen Kameras die
irgendwie haben und wahrscheinlich mehr als 10 Millionen.
Den Braten haben die Amis gerochen. Ja, und muss man mal sagen,
hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, dass es in Amerika noch so viel kritisches Denken gibt.
Auf jeden Fall wunderschön, dass dir als Firma deinen Superbowl-Spot schief
geht und um die Ohren fliegt.
Da gibt es sicherlich wunderschöne Beispiele, auch historischer Natur,
aber da wird schon jemand seinen Job verlieren.
Ja, ich glaube, in den USA, in den USA beginnt jetzt mit Trump 2,
auch so langsam sensibel zu werden für diese Privatsphäre und Überwachungsthemen.
Das sind, sagen wir mal, der deutschen Paranoia noch um Jahrzehnte hinterher,
aber immerhin hat es mal angefangen.
Währenddessen versucht Deutschland und Europa irgendwie zu sagen,
lass mal gucken, was es noch so für Alternativen gibt, dass wir die haben.
War ja auch, hatte ich glaube ich schon erzählt, es war ja wieder DIT und ich
war in Portugal, in Lissabon beim DIT und so.
Und in Berlin war der Spiegel beim DIT im Ixhain. gibt es einen schönen Artikel, den haben wir verlinkt.
Schönen Bericht, wo ja auch behandelt wird, dass da nicht ganz so viele Leute waren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob im Artikel auch drin steht, dass irgendwie Minus sonst was
gerade war und in Berlin das war zur Zeit, wo man darüber diskutiert hat, Salz zu streuen und so.
Also wo dann, wie heißt der, dieser FDP-Typ dann da irgendwie noch gesagt hat,
hier, ich streue jetzt hier Salz und so.
Das war wirklich bitterlich kalt und gemessen daran waren dann doch relativ viele Leute da.
Hier ist also ein Artikel drüber. Im Tagesspiegel wird das Thema behandelt und
ich habe im Rahmen der Berlinale bei so einem an einer Fachhochschule in Berlin
auch noch einen Vortrag dazu gehalten.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist.
Jetzt gehen Unis hin und sagen, ja, okay,
vielleicht könnten wir ja von Microsoft 365 uns lösen und vielleicht könnten
wir ja dieses Open Desk mal verwenden.
Haben wir uns mal darüber Gedanken gemacht, ob wir vielleicht nicht unsere Unis dafür nutzen,
Menschen an Microsoft-Produkte direkt zu gewöhnen da kann man jetzt unterschiedlich
drauf blicken, man kann auch sagen, naja, wenn die kein Microsoft lernen,
was sollen sie dann in der Arbeitswelt, aber irgendwo muss man ja anfangen so,
wenn die sagen, wir wollen,
OpenDesk verwenden, dann sagt OpenDesk, ja, das kostet 45 Euro netto pro Nutzer
und ja und natürlich auch für die Studierenden.
Und was sagt Microsoft? Die Studierenden sind natürlich kostenlos. Also.
Ich kann nur sagen, es ist eine Sache von Subventionen.
Und wenn du als Staat sagst, das kostet aber was, das ist eindeutig,
das braucht man gar nicht anzugucken, um zu wissen, dass Open Desk natürlich
das unterlegene Produkt ist.
Aber wenn du dann auch noch sagst, naja, wenn ihr jetzt hier die europäische
Alternative, die ist halt scheiße, aber dafür teurer, die kostet halt Geld.
So wirst du es ja nicht schaffen, mit diesem Open Desk Ding mit Microsoft zu konkurrieren.
Die lachen sich doch ins Fäustchen und sagen, ey super, die schreiben da auch
noch einen Preis dran, die Vollidioten.
Was Schöneres können wir gar nicht haben. Wir schenken das den Studierenden
und die sind irgendwann fertig, die sind dann schon Microsoft-Kunden,
die haben schon unsere T-Shirts an und die nächsten 40 Berufsjahre machen die nichts anderes mehr.
Also was finanzieren die denn daraus?
Wahrscheinlich die Entwicklung und den Betrieb. Also das Entscheidende ist einfach nur,
die wirtschaftliche vorherrschende Stellung, die kriegst du ja nicht dadurch,
dass du von Beginn an einen fairen Preis machst.
Die gewinnst du dadurch, dass
du halt einen Preis machst, der für jede andere Konkurrenz ruinös ist.
Überhaupt die Idee, Studierenden Geld abzunehmen oder den Unis für die Anzahl
ihrer Studierenden Geld abzunehmen, wenn sie auf eine Microsoft-Alternative
gehen, die kannst du doch nur haben, wenn du wirklich,
richtig lange nicht geatmet hast. So richtig lange.
Das ist schon wirklich ziemlich blöd. Also ich meine, das ist vor allem der
beste Weg überhaupt, so ein System mal ins Spiel zu bringen.
Ja, genau. Ja, wir haben 20 Jahre aufzuholen und der Abstand nimmt exponentiell zu.
Aber dafür kosten wir halt 45 Euro statt Knoppis.
Du weißt doch, wenn es nichts kostet, ist es auch nichts wert.
Ja.
So wie unser Podcast.
Unser Podcast ist was wert.
Unser Podcast ist kostenlos für Studenten, auf jeden Fall.
Ich hoffe, du warst auch, genau, wir sind kostenlos für Studenten.
Wir konkurrieren mit, mit wem konkurrieren wir?
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es Bezahl-Podcasts? Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe diese Dreisat-Dinge noch nicht angeguckt.
Da waren ja andere Podcasts drin.
Ich habe nur gesehen, du warst in einer Dreisat-Doku mit Markus Lanz.
Ja, das stimmt. Mit Markus Lanz und auch noch so ein paar Helden meiner Jugend,
wie zum Beispiel Kalkofer und Oliver Welke und andere Leute, die Podcasts machen.
Das war eine Doku für Dreisaat über Podcasts.
Die halt diesen Podcast-Boom aufgreift jetzt 20 Jahre nach dem Podcast.
Du den gelauncht hast.
Ja, weiß nicht. Ich bin ja schon länger als 20 Jahre unterwegs mit Podcasts
und kann jetzt lange darüber diskutieren, wann das jetzt wirklich angefangen hat.
Das haben sie halt versucht, da abzubilden.
Ja, so.
Versucht abzubilden klingt?
Naja, wie willst du denn so ein Thema im Fernsehen behandeln?
Das musst du im Podcast behandeln.
Der Podcast-Woo, wir schreiben wie so ein Zeitungsartikel übers Internet.
Ich war so ein bisschen,
ich weiß nicht, ich habe zu wenig geschlafen vor diesem Interview.
Ich war nicht so gut in Form.
Warst du so aufgeregt?
Die Fragen, aufgeregt nicht, aber ich war so ein bisschen unausgeschlafen und
dann sind einfach diese, du kennst das ja auch, wie so Fernsehinterviews so laufen,
dann, keine Ahnung, ich bin es halt gewohnt und das ist ja auch der Grund,
warum ich Podcasts mache,
den Gedanken aus dem Gespräch heraus zu entwickeln.
Und Fernsehen ist halt immer noch sehr viel mehr auf vorsortierte,
zack, zack, zack, jetzt hast du ja irgendwie die Antworten und das funktioniert
ja gut, wenn du so ein Thema,
was weiß ich, wenn du dich darauf vorbereitest und so weiter,
ich wusste jetzt gar nicht so richtig, was für Fragen mich da so treffen,
wenn das hat irgendwie nicht so richtig gut gepasst.
Am Ende ist es schon alles nicht so schlimm, aber es ist jetzt auch kein Meisterwerk.
Also die anderen, die ganzen Fernsehstars haben bessere Fernsehbeiträge über
ihren Podcast gemacht als du.
Ist dein Fazit.
Nee, das wollte ich damit nicht sagen. Jeder hat ja irgendwas anderes gesagt
und in der Gänze würde ich sagen, hat der,
sagen wir mal, so die wesentlichen Aussagen, die man so über Podcasts sagen
muss, kamen insgesamt so zusammen.
Ich glaube, ich hätte gerne noch ein paar klügere Sachen gesagt,
aber entweder habe ich nicht die richtigen Fragen bekommen oder nicht die richtigen
Antworten gegeben, ist ja jetzt sozusagen auch nur ein Bruchteil von dem,
was man da im Dialog aufnimmt,
landet am Ende ja in so einem Ding, weil das ja immer alles so zeitlich so beschränkt ist.
Also ich würde das ja nie sagen, wenn ein Mikrofon läuft, aber es ist ein Fehler,
Tim, in die Nähe einer TV-Kamera zu gehen und darauf zu warten,
dass jemand was fragt und dann darauf zu antworten.
Ja. du meinst, ich muss einfach selber reden.
Du musst einfach vorher wissen, was du sagen willst und dann die Frage einfach ignorieren.
Das habe ich auch versucht, aber ich war halt nicht ausgeschlossen.
Also das lernt man ja auch, wenn man im Fernsehen guckt, deswegen kriegt man
auch Kopfschmerzen, wenn man im Fernsehen guckt, weil die ganze Zeit Gespräche
stattfinden, wo man immer denkt, hä, der hat ja keine Idee.
Ist ja nur Fernsehen. Ist ja nur Fernsehen, guckt ja keiner.
Was ich im Podcast sage, das ist viel wichtiger.
Das ist entschuldigung. Es gilt das gesprochene Wort.
So sieht es aus.
Und Epicenter Works suchen einen Junior Policy Advisor für eine unbefristete
Anstellung im Ausmaß von 30 Wochenstunden in Gleitzeit.
Die Position richtet sich bewusst an Menschen am Anfang ihrer beruflichen Laufbahn,
die Interesse an juristischer und netzpolitischer Arbeit haben und sich in diesem
Bereich weiterentwickeln möchten.
Also zum Meta-Lobbyisten und dann zum Berichterstatter.
Du arbeitest von Beginn inhaltlich mit, wirst dabei aber eng begleitet.
Gemeinsam mit erfahrenen KollegInnen beschäftigst du dich mit aktuellen Fragen
rund um Digitalisierung, Grundrechte und Netzpolitik,
unterstützt bei Stellungnahmen und Positionen und lernst Schritt für Schritt,
wie zivilgesellschaftliche Policy-Arbeit in der Praxis funktioniert.
Und diese Praxis befindet sich in Wien.
Je nach Interesse bekommst du Einblicke in Öffentlichkeit, in Medienarbeit,
vom Text für die Website bis hin zum Interview.
Interview, vorher wissen wir, was man sagt, nicht von den Fragen ablenken lassen.
Genau, Epicenter Works natürlich die Organisation für die Thomas viel unterwegs
ist, der ja hier vor zwei Sendungen zu Gast war,
oder was heißt zu Gast, der hier vor zwei Sendungen wieder war und seit vielen
Jahren immer wieder hier in der Sendung ist und ich glaube auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik unter Team,
geführt wird Ja.
Was braucht ihr? starkes Interesse an Digitalisierung, Netzpolitik und Grundrechten
und ein abgeschlossenes oder fortgeschrittenes Studium mit juristischem Schwerpunkt.
Zum Beispiel Jura oder Wirtschaftsrecht oder Master of Human Rights.
Ich wusste nicht, dass es das gibt als Studium, aber das wäre,
das ist schon ein schöner Titel.
Ja, also wenn ihr Bock habt bei Epicenter zu arbeiten, Link in den Shownotes.
Damit sind wir durch. Ja, okay, gut, super.
Eine lange Sendung. Gut.
Mir fällt jetzt gar nicht mehr so sehr viel ein, was ich jetzt am Schluss noch
sagen kann. Ich frage mal meinen AI-Agent.
Und was sagt er?
Ich weiß nicht, schläft gerade.
Damit beschäftigt, das Internet zu zerstören.
Ja, weißt du, wir haben ja früher ein Buch gelesen, sind auf dem Baum geklettert.
Mit Super Mario sind wir auf dem Baum geklettert, am Gameboy.
Ich bin wirklich auf dem Baum geklettert, ich bin sogar runtergefallen.
Ja, klar, das habe ich mir fast gedacht, dass du mal irgendwas scheinbar vom Baum gefallen hast.
Man muss auch vom Baum runtergefallen sein.
Even monkeys fall from trees.
Jetzt verstehe ich es endlich.
Oh Mann, du findest auch alles raus.
So, tschüss. Genießt das Internet, solange ihr es noch habt.
Das langst du auch stehst.
Sonst müssen wir zurück auf die Bäume. Auch scheiße.
Naja, aber könnte dann auch wieder runterfallen, wenn ihr Spaß dran habt. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.